Guten Morgen Tim. Da wäre ich doch gar nicht ins Flugzeug gekommen, um hier wieder hinzukommen.
Logbuch, Netzpolitik Nummer zweihundertundfünfzehn frisch wiedervereint.
Ja. Noch, also eigentlich sind wir jetzt frisch getrennt worden, weißt du, ne? Ja, deine äh dein Start so behauptet hat gerade den Austritt aus der Europäischen Union eingereicht, mein Lieber.
Beantragt.
Ja, wie auch immer, der die Verträge sind gemacht.
Das ist nicht mein Staatsoberhaupt, das Staatsoberhaupt, das ist die Queen.
Okay, das lasse ich gelben. Aber äh müssen wir uns mal überlegen, wie wie lange wir das denn jetzt hier, wie lange wir dich jetzt hier noch dulden, ne.
Tja.
Ihr seid eures eigenen Schmiedesglück.
Was soll ich, was soll ich was soll ich zünden.
Ich werde keine Drecksitzwitze. Deswegen mache ich die so gerne.
Ja, na ja, also ich will nicht sagen, ich stehe da jetzt drüber, aber.
Man merkt, dass dir das an dir kratzt. Das ist schon okay, du kannst auch Gefühle zeigen. Ja, verstehe ich.
Ja das kratzt wirklich an mir. Aber es kratzt halt, also ich meine, ich ich persönlich komme da ja relativ elegant raus aus der Nummer.
Wie denn jetzt nochmal.
Ja, ich werde halt deutsche Staatsbürgerschaft annehmen, fertig.
Annehmen. Meinst du ernsthaft, dass du die sowas musst du dir verdien.
Nein, das wird man mir natürlich angetragen. Für besondere Verdienste,
Ich habe ja schon mehrfach abgelehnt. Ja, nee, ach komm, noch nee, lass mal und so. Aber jetzt denke ich mir so, ach Gott, wenn ihr unbedingt wollt, dann mache ich halt mit bei eurem Verein, dann wähle ich auch mal,
Kanzler und so, werde schon sehen, was ihr davon habt, was ich dann hier für Gott Kanzler mir aussuche, die irgendwie gerade so im Angebot sind, ne,
Nee, aber es tut mir einfach Leid, um um die paar Briten, die da noch äh übrig sind, die,
einerseits halt äh ja einfach auch Europa fühlen und irgendwie auch mal verstehen, was Europa ist.
Und die besonders leid tut's mir natürlich einfach auch um die Jugend.
Weil es war ja nun auch schon ein Votum der Alten. Das hat man ja schon an den Wahlergebnissen gesehen. Das war einfach sechzig Plus.
Dann kommen die endlich mal von der Insel runter. Ja, die Jugend.
Die Jugend, die kommt auch von der Insel runter. Die Jugend ist schon auch äh stark europäisiert und hängt einfach nicht mehr so tief in dieser ganzen Fallgrube eines eines verloren gegangenen Empires,
Ich meine, das ist ja wirklich.
Da klammern sich einfach Leute an an ein Bild eines eines Landes, was einfach schon längst äh mit Elbes zusammen aus dem Haus ist,
Und und das ist so so die Ursuppe, in dem da halt einfach äh gefischt wurde.
Äh ein sehr guter Freund verwerte die Situation mal jemand
nach dem Genuss eines Mittags seines ersten Mittagessen in in England. Bei dieser Reise so zusammengefasst
Wenn man hier einmal gegessen hat, dann weiß man warum die
in alle Ehrenländer gefahren sind, auf der Suche nach besserem Essen und wahrscheinlich nie zurückgekehrt sind. Und das erklärt wahrscheinlich die äh Situation Großbritanniens heute.
Na ja, also kulinarisch haben sie ja übrigens genauso wie Berlin, den Vorteil, dass die ganze Welt ja zu ihnen gekommen ist und äh.
Wir wollen aber was landestypisches.
Kannst, du kannst ja, ich meine, das äh ich finde das Frühstück ja immer noch total knork, also also,
Also englisches Frühstück finde ich ist einfach eine Ansage so. Also es ist äh auf jeden Fall besser als dieses High Tight die äh Marmelade auf ein dünnes Croissant schmieren, französische Ding
und Deutschland weiß ich nicht, Frühstückskultur ist ja halt hier auch irgendwie nicht so richtig präsent, hier gibt's immer nur eine Antwort auf das Thema Essen. Wir haben Brot.
Und das ist aber gutes Brot.
Ja, das ist okay und so, das das zählt auch, aber.
Komm, hör auf mit.
Ich mache mir halt auch gerne nochmal eine Tomate warm, weißt du? Ich mache mir eine Tomate warm.
Tomate warm, Tim, ist in Ordnung. Musst du dir dann halt irgendwann mal abgewöhnen.
Jetzt erst rechts. Ja, aber du bist aus dem Urlaub wieder zurück, sehr schön äh und,
Deine, deine deine elektrischen Geräte, deine elektronischen Geräte wurden noch nicht ähm.
Nee, ich konnte noch so ins Flugzeug in alle in alle Flüge, war kein Problem.
Ein letzter, ein ein letzte Mal ein an der universellen globalen Freiheit geschnuppert. Hm.
Ja, mal gucken. Äh nun kaum war ich wieder in in Deutschland, klingelte das Handy und dann Hauptstadtjournalisten dran, ne? Ja ähm,
Hier ähm wissen sie irgendwas von dem Hacker, von dem neuen Hackerangriff auf den Bundestag. Ich so, ich habe damit nichts zu tun, ehrlich.
Nee, aber es kann doch sein, dass sie irgendwie ich war ich war weg, ich.
Ich habe Bali wie.
Äh damit kotzt du wahrscheinlich heutzutage auch nicht mehr durch. Nee, dann habe ich ähm, habe ich gesagt, nee, weil also tatsächlich wusste ich nicht, bin ein bisschen irgendwie mich ferngehalten,
Und ähm heute kam dann die kam dann die Meldung, denn das äh des BSI verkündete nicht ohne Stolz,
dass es ein Hackerangriff auf den Bundestag untersucht hat und beruhigenderweise feststellen konnte, dass da nichts Schlimmes passiert ist.
Aber das ist jetzt eigentlich gar keine neue Nachricht.
Das war der, das war der Gag. Also ich will mal ganz kurz äh ich habe mir dann so diese Passwette durchgelesen und dann da sind zwei sehr schöne, wichtige Sachen drin. Ähm,
Arne Schönbumm, der Präsident des BSI erklärt dazu. Cyro-Angriffe mit Hilfe von manipulierten Webseiten,
gehören zum Standardrepertoire von Cyberangreifern und sind aus technischer Sicht nichts besonderes. Das BSI geht davon aus, dass die Abwehrmechanismen des Deutschen Bundestags die Zugriffe auf diese Webseite dektiert und abgefangen haben. Der Angriff wurde somit abgewehrt.
Naja, ich irgendwie habe ich hier so ein bisschen gelesen und stand hier irgendwie, dass die die betroffene Seite, wo die Webseite der Jerusalem Post gewesen wäre.
Habe ich irgendwie überlegt, okay, das ähm,
ein bisschen nachgelassen. Die Seite der, also hier steht die Webseite der Post war manipuliert und hat auf eine schädliche Drittseite verlinkt,
Ähm da riechst du schon worum's langsam geht. Also offenbar wurde nicht die Gerissel im Post gehackt, sondern,
Eine Drittseite, die sie verlinkt und was verlinken, Webseiten und gerade so Nachrichtenseiten für Drittseiten,
Werbenetzwerke ein Werbe-Netzwerk war betroffen.
Und dann stellte dann auch der Arne äh Schönboom fest. Wo ist das denn?
Er hat dann auch das wie, was haben die das gelöscht? Das gibt's doch nicht.
Was denn? Du sagst hier eine der Hauptursachen dieser Drive-By-Eingriffe sind schädliche Werbebanner.
Wo worum finde ich das nicht,
Ach so, nee, das äh steht offen, man sagt nicht eher, das, ich habe nach Q Text gesucht, genau. Eine der Hauptursachen für solche für diese sogenannten Drive-By-Angriffe sind schädliche Werbebanner. Das heißt, wir haben's jetzt schriftlich,
Vom BSI, dass das Haupteinfallstor wie man sich ein Trojaner oder irgendwelchen irgendwelches Ungemach im Internet einfängt,
Werbung, Werbebanner sind,
Weshalb wir auch jedem und jeder Nutzerinnen und Nutzer und äh und Wesen im Internet und Kühlschrank im Internet dazu raten
nur mit Adlocker zu surfen und ich bin froh, ähm dass diese
dass der, dass das BSI das nun auch offiziell einmal sagt und ich bin ganz besonders vor das kurz zuvor wenige Tage davor.
Auch noch im, äh, bei Netzpolitik Org ein Interview mit
Thorsten Schröder vom Chaos-Computerclub erschien, indem er auch nochmal ausführlich davor gewarnt hat und das ist nämlich, denke ich, in dieser gesamten Applocker Blockerdebatte
Ein sehr entscheidender Punkt, denn so kannst du äh nicht nur einfach irgendjemanden infizieren, sondern da diese Netzwerke ja ähm,
Quasi ihre Kunden sehr gut kennen oder die die Webseitenbesucher über die Webseiten tracken, weil es einfach nur wenige Netzwerke gibt und die auf fast jeder Seite vertreten sind oder auf sehr vielen Seiten vertreten sind,
Verfolgen sie den Nutzer quasi durch die Welt und sehen, ich male jetzt so einen Fall aus, du machst morgen irgendwie was morgens auf, guckst erstmal irgendwie,
YouTube irgendwas oder sowas, ne? Ist jetzt direkt ein schlechtes Beispiel, Beispiel bei YouTube Google gehört, aber guckst irgendwie fünf Nachrichtenseiten
Und auf drei davon oder fünf davon ist das gleiche Ednetzwerk und weiß, dass du all das besucht hast und mach daraus eben dann Vorhersagen über deine Interessen, um besser zielgerichtete Werbung zu machen,
Gleichzeitig kannst du dann im Backend dieser äh Werbe-Netzwerke, wo die Werbung geschaltet wird, sagen, ich möchte gerne keine Ahnung so.
Briten, Anfang vierzig gerne mit meiner Werbung beglücken, die sich für Podcasting interessieren und dann wird entsprechend von den Werbenetzwerk gehandelt und diese Zielgruppe,
angezielt. Das wiederum hat noch einen ganz anderen, sehr viel interessanteren Aspekt, dass du nämlich,
Die Zielgruppe so genau definieren kannst, dass du mit großer Wahrscheinlichkeit ähm,
sagen wir mal Manager, Politiker oder sonstiges triffst, wenn du weißt, wie du diese Zielgruppen definierst, weil sowas wie Einkommen oder sowas ist da eine ganz normale Kategorie
In diesen äh in diesen Werbenetzwerken, was mich zu der Vermutung verleitete, zu denken, ha nicht, dass jetzt etwa,
sich das doch um einen gezielten Angriff handelte für auf vielleicht bestimmte Parlamentarier, die sich äh diesem Post lesen,
Dann habe ich einfach mal gedacht, okay, nehmen wir mal Big Data, ne? Nehmen wir mal Google,
und geben ein Jerusalem Post Mevertising, Geneury ähm und siehe da, ich fand sofort eine Meldung, die ähm,
ich auch verlinkt hatte und jetzt doch gerade nicht finde. Eine Meldung von so einer ähm,
Forschungsbude, die über eine Kampagne ähm auf aufklärte.
Die unter anderem äh Rotten Tomatos.
DJ Rissed Post und andere Veröffentlicher betraf
Und dieser Artikel wurde veröffentlicht im am achtundzwanzigsten Januar, das heißt wer irgendwie das Blog von Merwurby, Slaps liest, der wusste auch schon
im Januar als nämlich genau dieser Hackerangriff stattgefunden haben soll auf dem Bundestag, dass es hier
Eine Mehrurteilsin Kampagne gibt, die diese Seiten betrifft.
Und wir hatten auch schon nach der letzten Republika vor gut einem Jahr ähm haben wir das Thema ja auch schon mal aufgegriffen, weil ja damals THS.
Thorsten Schröder, den ich gerade erwähnt hatte.
Genau, Thorsten Schröder und Frank Rieger genau zu diesem Thema dort einen Vortrag gehalten haben, den verlinken wir auch nochmal
Edwars, wo im Prinzip genau das, was du jetzt gerade beschrieben hast, nochmal so im Detail dargelegt wurde und auch demonstriert wurde
Alter Hut. So, was heißt das jetzt? Äh kann gut sein, dass dieser gloriose Bundestagshack. Ich meine, wir reden jetzt von dem Ding, wo dann irgendwie die ganze Zeit über Russen äh äh Angriffe diskutiert wurde, ja
die ja da auch nach wie vor gerne hinterstecken äh äh können. Man weiß ja jetzt nicht, wer das jetzt gemacht hat, aber das Interessante ist natürlich, dass jetzt hier
gar nicht mal so diese ominöse typische Hollywoodszene von Hacker mit Maske klopft an die Türe
und und guckt mal, wo man reinkommt, sondern äh man sitzt eigentlich gemütlich da und wartet, bis sozusagen der Angreifer selbst
vorbeikommt. Und dann äh kriegt man das einfach kurz signalisiert. Da macht so Bimmelbimmel, ach ihr Kunde ist da und dann so, ja dann verzählen wir doch mal.
Das Opfer kommt vorbei, nicht der Angriffer. Ja.
Das das Kunde sagte ich oder.
Das gerade, aber weißt du, du hast, hat der Angreifer kommt vorbei. Nee, nee, der, der Angreifer wartet, bis der.
Das Opfer äh kommt sozusagen selber zum sich über die Rüberhauen äh vorbei. So ein bisschen.
Und das ist 'ne, das ist 'ne sehr, das ist aus verschiedenen Gründen sehr elegante Methode, also einerseits, weil du das einfach wie eine Werbeanzeige schalten kannst.
Und andererseits, weil du soeben dir das Fishing sparst, ne? Du musst jetzt nicht irgendwie sagen, klick mal hier oder lade mal runter oder halt Rechnung im Anhang und alles, was du brauchst, ist irgendwie ein
eine halbwegs aktuelle Exploid offenbrowser, davon gibt's viele, deswegen werden Browser so oft geupdatet und noch viel schöner wie auch von,
von Thorsten da in dem Video dokumentiert eine Schwachstelle in einem Brow in einer Browser Extension.
Also allein von der Code Komplexität her und von den ganzen Extensions her bieten Browser einfach unglaubliche Angriffsoberfläche und ähm
über diese Werbeanzeigen hat man ein sehr komfortablen Weg die Menschen anzugreifen ohne dass sie sich aus ihrem normalen
Habitat herausbewegen müssen, ne? Ähm wir hatten solche Fälle auch schon öfter mal bei deutschen,
Werbeseiten, das also bei deutschen Nachrichtenseiten, dass die dann ähm ähm kurzzeitig mehrwert in ihrer Werbung drin hat,
Schlecht. Also die Nachricht die die Nachricht lautet eigentlich ist nicht, es gab einen Hackerangriff auf den Deutschen Bundestag, sondern die Nachricht lautet im Jahre zweitausendsiebzehn haben Rechner des deutschen Bundestages
keine Applocker und das ist ein Problem, das betrachte ich wirklich als Problem. Also wenn ich irgendwie gefragt werde, hier äh Neumann, du,
erklär mal, wie ich meinen Computer sicher mache, dann ist ähm installiere einen AdBlocker das Erste.
Das ist einfach äh vor allem eine Maßnahme, die jeden Menschen dann auch glücklich macht, der denkt so, oh, boah, was, da ist ja irgendwie hinter der, hinter dem ganzen Geblinke ist ja Inter, da ist ja Inhalt, da kann ich ja noch was sehen. Also das ähm,
Das denke ich ist eher die Meldung, die hier eigentlich stattfindet. Nichtsdestotrotz freuen wir uns natürlich, ähm dass das offenbar hier kein Angriff geglückt ist
Also aus welchen Gründen auch immer, das BSI sagt, dass Lega an ihrem Schutzschild oder was auch immer, kann sehr gut sein, dass die die Verbindungen da zu bestimmten IP-Adressen schon gelöscht haben, äh, gebloggt haben, weil
Weil die bekannt sind als als bösartige IP-Adressen kann sein, dass es alles nur Glück ist, kann sein, dass der, dass es zwar kein Ad-Block hat dafür aber einen sicheren,
Oder auf dem aktuellen standgehaltenen Browser gab, wer weiß es aber die Nachricht an unsere Freunde,
in den verschiedenen Instituten, Institutionen in Berlin und Bonn lautet. Fragt doch mal nach dem AdBlocker, dann habt ihr die Sorge auch nicht mehr.
Man sollte vielleicht auch mal klarstellen, ähm diese Security definierte Sicht auf AdBlocker richtet sich,
Eigentlich nicht unbedingt jetzt zwingend gegen Werbung als solche, sondern,
konkret über Werbung, die über Werbenetzwerke von dritten Quellen,
die mehr oder weniger dynamisch ausgewählt werden, ausgeliefert werden. Es gibt ja mittlerweile auch schon so einen Wandel. Man sieht das so bei Spiegel Online, anderen Postillen, wo dann die Werbungen zunehmenden Maße von den eigenen Servern kommen,
Die Zeitung und Publikation in dem Moment noch dieselbe,
Kontrolle über die Inhalte, was dort ausgeliefert wird, haben wie mit ihrem eigenen Content, das bleibt,
beobachten, ja? Ist allerdings zumindest schon mal nicht ganz so verdächtig, so drive by äh mäßig äh äh rüberzukommen, wo halt.
Irgendwie dynamisch irgendeinen Server in dem Moment ausgewählt wird, der sich einfach kurz bei irgendeiner
online Auktion gemeldet hat mit ach ja genau hier meine Zielgruppe, ich biete X und dann kommt halt die Werbung
dass es halt das Kernproblem, weil es ja natürlich jetzt auch ein bisschen in diese Adlocker, Blocker äh Debatte reinmündet, ja, wo das ja immer so ein Argument ist, äh at Blocker beschützen mich irgendwie vor dem bösen Internet
absolut valides Argument und das muss da zumindest mit eingeflossen werden, aber da geht's halt jetzt nicht per se um die Werbung als Zeug.
Genau, also sie schützen dich auch vor dem Tracking durch diese Netzwerke.
Netzwerke. Kommt noch dazu.
Schützen dich vor,
Tatsächlich einfach muss man einfach so sagen, unkontrollierten Inhalten, die dann mitgeladen werden und damit eben dann auch gegen,
an potenzielle Hackingangriffe.
Aber man muss auch sagen, dass das Web bleibt einfach auch ein rüder Ort,
Das ist halt einfach äh schwierig und es ist halt vor allem die Offenheit des Webs, die es an der Stelle einfach knifflig macht. Äh entsprechende Sicherheitsmaßnahmen einzuziehen, die global in Santan für alle wirken könnten,
Meine ist schon mal ganz gut, dass jetzt so Sachen wie Flash. Doch mehr oder weniger konsequent äh herausgenommen werden. Ich find's halt immer noch ein bisschen albern, wenn dann diese Publikationen dann beim Aufruf der Webseite auch sich immer noch darüber beklagen, dass Flash nicht installiert ist im Jahre zwanzig.
Das ist das ist dann der zweite Rat, äh also diesen Flashplayer, den kannst du natürlich nicht holen auf deinem Rechner. Das geht nicht.
Ja, aber gibt's halt immer noch Seiten, die sich schwer tun und äh.
Ja, das ist dann das ist dann deren Problem.
Sollte es eigentlich sein, so, aber du weißt ja, wie dein äh Nutzer reagieren. So, oh, mein Computer ist was falsch. Ich klicke den Button, damit's wieder heile ist so. Dann war's das.
Installieren sie den Flashplayer und installieren sie bitte den die neue Version des Flashflairs war auch lange Zeit Klassiker, klassisches äh Fishing oder oder,
äh Utan. Aber wir wollen jetzt nicht, glaube ich, ähm Lockbuch Security würde ich super gerne machen, aber mache ich schon den ganzen Tag,
Jetzt ist hier Logbuch Netzpolitik. Ich oder so, haben wir noch ein bisschen was.
Nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, ich dachte nur, ich sage auch mal was kluges.
Hast du Tim keine Sorge, du hast deinen klugen Satz für diese Sendung gesagt?
Danke, kann ich jetzt gehen?
Oh, jetzt kannst du, jetzt musst du, jetzt musst du kluge Sätze sagen, weil jetzt vergesse ich mich. Ja ähm.
Bei der Münchner Sicherheitskonferenz, die glaube ich vor zwei oder drei Monaten war, ne?
Nee, solange ist der Trump schon am Monat, ist das jetzt glaube ich her.
Ne? Bei der.
Maximal.
Bei der Münchner Sicherheitskonferenz übergab der Chef des türkischen Geheimdienstes mit,
Eine Liste mit Namen von Hunderten in Deutschland lebenden angeblichen Gülenanhängern an den Präsidenten des BND,
Ähm Güllen,
ist der Mann, der in den USA im Exil wohnt und dem also Fetula Güllen, dem irgendwie,
In die Schuhe geschoben wird, er habe diesen damaligen sehr kläglich gescheiterten Putsch gegen Erdogan ähm in die Wege geleitet, bewegt. Belege dafür, bleiben die,
Bleibt die türkische Regierung und die türkischen Geheimdienste schuldig. Wir erinnern uns, dass dieser Putsch ohnehin eine sehr,
nachdenkliche denkwürdige Geschichte war und ähm das ist so ungefähr der Staatsfeind Nummer eins der Türkei.
Ähm weil er das Oberhaupt der islamischen äh Güllenbewegung ist oder Gylähenbewegung. Ich weiß nicht, wie man die ausspricht. Heute Morgen im Deutschlandradio haben sie gesagt, Göllen.
Also ich ich habe auch wenig Kenntnis über türkische Aussprache, aber was ich äh vor allem immer gehört habe, ist Gülen.
Finde ich auch, fand ich auch, aber heute Morgen war, wer war da im Radio? Ich Georg Masko oder Hans Leinendecker oder sowas im Deutschlandradio, die haben Deutschlandfunk, die haben gesagt, Gülen.
Nur noch nur noch Gülle im Deutschland.
Seht es uns nach.
Jetzt kriegt er, jetzt kriegt er äh jetzt kriegt also der der Präsident des BND Holger Münch, wenn ich mich nicht täusche.
Oder verwechsle ich den jetzt gerade mit dem BKA-Chef,
Nein, Holger Mühl. Nein, habe ich verwechselt. Dann ist es prodokal, Entschuldigung. Ähm dann hat der, dann hat er das also Podokal gegeben. Das müssen wir irgendwie schneiden. Ich hatte drei Wochen Urlaub. Ich darf sowas vergessen.
Also er hat das Produkt in die Hand gedrückt und der hat sich das angeschaut und hat gedacht, na ja okay, da sind irgendwie Meldeadressen drauf. Ähm Handy und Festnetznummern und Fotos von diesen Leuten muss ich mir mal irgendwie anschauen.
Aber warte mal, warte mal, warte mal. Dem BND? Dem Auslandsgeheimdienst der Bundesrepublik Deutschland gibt er.
Deutsche Geheimdienstwelt, schwere Geheimdienstfel.
Ähm.
Chef des äh türkischen Geheimdienstes wohl vertan. Du hast Recht, ähm eigentlich hätte er sich an.
Verfassungsschutz oder.
Müssen an denen nämlich an den Inlandsgeheimnissen. Das ist richtig. Wahrscheinlich hat man aber auch in der Türkei die Zeitung gelesen und hat gedacht, mit dem PND kann man sowas mach.
Stellt sich eh keiner quer zur Not wird einfach ein neues Gesetz, aber dann geht das auch.
So, das kann, das kann natürlich auch sein. Aber natürlich wichtiger Punkt. Äh formal hätte wäre er beim Verfassungsschutz richtig gewesen und dann hätte er das dem ähm dem Herrn,
Maaßen, jetzt muss ich immer Namen sagen, um zu zeigen, dass ich dem Georg Maaßen in die Hand Hände gedrückt.
Du kennst ja auch alle, ne?
Bei dem willst du mal auch nicht wie die Geschichte weitergegangen wäre, hätte es vielleicht eine ganz andere Wendung nehmen können, wenn man so dessen Rechtsauffassung mal studiert. Ähm,
schaut sich das also an und sagt, ja, sind neben die Mail-Adressen, Handynummern und vor allem Fotos der Betroffenen drauf. Und wundert sich und stellt fest, dass etliche dieser Fotos offenbar heimlich aufgenommen wurden,
durch Überwachungskameras oder so. Irgendwie alles ein sehr komisches Dossier. Also ich glaube es waren dreihundert Personen,
zweihundert Vereine, wo die Hochdecks, meine Güte, ne? Also wahrscheinlich irgendwie jeder jeder Kulturverein auf der Hermannstraße so ungefähr, ne? Also.
Der noch nicht komplett auf Linie ist so.
Ja genau, wo wo mal jemand gesagt hat, dass der Erdogan vielleicht irgendwie auch mal.
Kurz durchatmen könnte vorm nächsten Schrei. Na ja. Da haben sie sich überlegt, so dann schauten sie sich das an und sagten, ja hör mal, das scheint doch so zu sein. Das hier der türkische Geheimdienst.
Offenbar äh diesen Menschen in Deutschland ausspioniert und dann haben wir doch hier einen klaren Fall von äh Geheimdiensttätigkeit
Gegenbewohner unseres Landes, die hier, was weiß ich, unter welchen Bedingungen offenbar leben und zwar so dauerhaft.
Nicht nur Bewohner, sondern auch Staat.
Und ja und auch staatsbürger dieses Landes, äh die hier wahrscheinlich aus gutem Grund wohnen. Dann haben sich dann und das finde ich natürlich sehr löblich
Die äh als sich der BND daran gemacht, diesen Menschen darüber in Kenntnis zu setzen und zu warnen. Dieser Prozess ist irgendwie im Gange, das muss man natürlich auch erstmal hinkriegen, da arbeiten jetzt dann irgendwie die verschiedenen äh Behörden mit und sagen diesen Leuten.
Bescheid und warnen sie vor allem und das ist auch das Ash für dich wiederum erschreckende daran
vor einer Beteiligung an dem Verfassungsreferendum der Türkei, was am sechzehnten April ansteht, wenn ich mich nicht täusche, bist du ein Sonntag sein. Ähm.
Also in der Türkei, ich glaube, in Deutschland haben die Wahlen jetzt schon angefangen oder sind sogar schon durch, ja.
Das kann sein. Genau, aber diese Wahlen finden natürlich auf türkischem Mohrheitsgebiet statt, nämlich dann im Konsulat oder in der,
in im in wie heißen die anderen Dinger Botschaft oder so? Und sagen also passt auf mit dem Betreten des türkischen Hoheitsgebietes, die haben's auf euch abgesehen,
ähm sowohl passt auf mit einer Einreihe, also mit einer Einreise und passt auf mit dem Betreten derer ähm derer Institution, die.
Wäre dann ein ganz äh interessantes, dezentes League der Türken, um die Leute von der Wahl abzuhalten.
Jetzt wenn es nur dreihundert Personen sind, glaube ich, das wird ja nicht wahlentscheidend sein, ne?
Zweihundert Vereine.
Ja, wobei der wahrscheinlich die Personen und Vereine da Überschneidungen haben werden.
Ja Freunde von Freunden mitgehangen, mitgefangen.
Also man kann das ist immer natürlich, man kann immer sofort auch in dieser Geheimdienstwelt berechtigter Weise den den,
Den Strang aufmachen, das ist ja auch vielleicht von dem türkischen Geheimdienst beabsichtigt, dicht gewesen sein kann, dass dies geschieht. Man kann aber auch.
Ja. Ich meine, wovon sind sie denn bitte ausgegangen? Sind sie wohl nicht etwa davon ausgegangen.
Möchtest du etwa jetzt irgendwie davon ausgehen, dass irgendwie, also dass,
In der momentanen Regierung und in den Geheimdiensten der Türkei noch irgendwie zehne Personen sind, die sinnvolle ähm,
Prognosen über die Zukunft und das Handeln anderer Menschen tätigen.
Also im Geheimdienst dürft ihr vielleicht nicht ganz so viele Köpfe gerollt sein, die nicht schon längst gerollt sind.
Da sind so viele Köpfe gerollt und ähm ich würde auf also von dem, was man jetzt so von
Erdogan irgendwie in den letzten Jahren schon an Handeln gesehen hat, würde ich davon ausgehen, dass der sich natürlich auch mit Leuten umgibt, die irgendwo in der Nähe seines Gedankenguts sind
und ähm also kann man jetzt drüber spekulieren, es ist.
Machen wir aber nicht.
Die Möglichkeit steht im Raum. Ich finde das erstmal ganz schön, dass wie der BND da reagiert hat. Man hätte sich gewünscht, dass der vor vielen Jahren in Bad Aibling auch schon so reagiert hätte. Da möchte ich,
vorsichtig an dieser Stelle auch drauf hinweisen, aber wir nehmen das Loben zur Kenntnis, äh dass das hier äh so.
Geschehen ist und dann jetzt
Die Nachrichten sind gerade voll von irgendwelchen deutschen Politikern, die da auch draufstanden. Michelle Müntefähring äh wird da irgendwie genannt und lächelt einen gerade von der Homepage der Tagesschau an. Das ist auch eine ganz schön große,
Nova. Und man kann sich natürlich auch fragen, wenn man sich überlegt, wie das diplomatische Verhältnis zwischen,
Deutschland der Bundesrepublik Deutschland und der Türkei in den letzten drei, vier Wochen gelitten hat, könnte man sogar spekulieren, dass es auch kein Zufall ist, dass es ausrechnet jetzt,
der BND, dem MIT mit dieser Nachricht in den Rücken fällt. Also man kann,
Man kann da sehr viel spekulieren, ne. Fassen wir mal kurz zusammen, was wir so gesehen haben irgendwie ähm also diese diese ewigen Beschimpfungen als als Nazi äh musste Angela Merkel über sich ergehen lassen. Mehrfach von,
von Erdogan. Ähm, wir haben diesen Konflikt mit Holland gehabt,
Hast du das also meine Güte? Dann haben die, also die Niederlande haben, also es geht darum, dass Vertreter der türkischen Regierung ja in,
Deutschland für dieses Verfassungsreferendum da Stimmung machen wollten, dass nämlich mehr oder weniger die die jetzige Verfassung,
abschafft und die Türkei in einem Präsidialsystem umwandelt und Erdogan dann irgendwie zum alleinigen Sonnengott äh machen soll.
Der Sultan.
Da sollte dann für geworben werden.
Martin Sonneborn immer so schön sagt, der irre vom Bosporus.
Dafür sollte geworben werden, dann haben eben ein einige Städte in Deutschland gesagt, ja, aber das irgendwie so aus formalen Gründen oder aus Sicherheitsgründen, möchten wir diese Veranstaltung eigentlich nicht haben bei uns
Und dann gab's gab's dann irgendwie natürlich sofort diese Nazivergleiche, den wir denen Deutschland sich dann aussetzen musste in Holland. Geschahnliches, die haben das aber irgendwie ein bisschen ehrlicher gemacht, die haben direkt gesagt, ist hier nicht erwünscht, fertig, Thema erledigt,
Und ähm dann kam mir so skurrile, also da muss man ja mal.
Ja, die Holländer waren natürlich auch alle Nazis und das muss man auch erstmal bringen. Das ist so schön. Das ist schon wirklich tough.
Da wurde es dann so, dass da wurd's dann skurril und ich ähm dann hatte irgend so ein türkischer Kuhzuchtverband.
Die niederländischen Kühe zurückgeschick,
weil eines ist offenbar das das stärkste oder entscheidender Handel zwischen den Niederlanden und der Türkei ist das die Türkei Milch, dass dass die Türkei Milchkühe aus Holland importiert.
Mhm. Und vor allem im großen Stil, ne, im.
Jetzt wollen wir die aber nicht mehr und jetzt schicken wir die zurück. Und irgendwann ein irgendwie ein ähm,
Ein Bezirksbürgermeister Istanbuls, ich glaube von Vioglo oder so, hat dann irgendwie auch noch so eine Kuh an die, ans Licht gezehrt und hat gesagt, wenn die Niederländer sich bis morgen nicht entschuldigen, dann schlachtet er diese Kuh.
Das gibt aber Ärger mit den Indern.
Ich meine was stellt ihr was? Also wenn ich meine, ich habe ja in Istanbul viel erlebt, ne? Aber wenn jetzt irgendwie dein Bezirksbürgermeister auf einmal
droht ein Tier zu töten und versucht damit Holland zu erpressen, ne? Dann weißt du irgendwann ernsthaft, dass du, dass du echt mal überlegen musst, was du, was du noch in diesem Land machst und das tun ja auch viele.
Tja, dann hätte man den Messermesser an Käse ansetzen sollen, ne, wenn sie wahrscheinlich steil gegangen.
Um das, den haben sie ja dann bezahlt, den können sie ruhig anschneiden, aber der ähm die Kür natürlich auch. Ähm dann.
Nur um das äh Feld noch kurz abzustecken, der das diplomatische Feld. Wir haben ja dann auch noch den deutschen deutsch-türkischen Journalisten Dennis Jüchsel,
Der ähm ja jetzt irgendwie da in den auch inzwischen seit Wochen in der Türkei
Als Spion festgehalten wird, weil er irgendwann mal ein Remote Erdogan kritische Stück verfasst hat und der ist da seit, also der ist mindestens seit Monater jetzt in Haft. Ich war äh ich weiß noch, wann die erste Demonstration war. Das war vor,
vor vier oder mehr Wochen in äh in Hamburg, Berlin und und mehreren Ständen ähm wurde dann mit einem Autochor so für die Freilassung äh dieses Journalisten,
bestritten. Wer äh demonstriert. Interessant muss ich aber auch sagen, also mit dem mit dem Cool zurückschicken und äh ihr fehlen k,
den die Tötung einer Kuh androhen und so. Ähm das sind ja schon interessante Dinge, aber dann haben Erdogan Anhänger auch noch Orangen ausgequetscht. Ähm in der in in Bezug auf Oranie, ne, die
die Idee von Oranien sind ja oder jene von Orania sind ja das Königsvolk, was da in Holland auch noch regiert
Holland ist ja dann eben auch eine Nationalfarbe, die treten ja im Fußball auch so an und dann haben irgendwelche AKP-Anhänger äh Orangen mit der Hand zerquetscht, um ihren Unmut, ihrem Unmut Ausdruck zu verleihen. Also, ich.
Das ist mal nicht Erdogans Verhältnis zu Donald Trump irgendwie hingefahren bringt.
Stimmt, kann auch anders gemeint gewesen sein.
Wie visionär waren eigentlich diese Leute, die irgendwie ein paar Monate vor der Wahl diese Fernsehserie Orange ist, new Black am Start gebracht haben.
Es ist nicht ein paar Monate, das ist lange davor gewes.
Ja, ist das so oder Jahre, dass wir jetzt nicht versehen sehen, nicht so.
Also erstmal doch, dann muss ich bei aller Kritik der Türkei dann doch nochmal meine große Anerkennung für äh türkische Demonstrationskultur hier,
Ausdruck bringen.
Ich hab ja vor also ich war eben, ich war nie auf Seiten der AKP, ich hab ja auch schon in in Istanbul mich an Demonstrationen beteiligt, ähm bin damals, äh, das hatte ich hier glaube ich auch erwähnt aus der Wahl im Gesi Park,
als der geräumt wurde und wurde da mit dem mit Granaten und mit irgendwie wie heißt dieser,
Knallbomben und und Tränengasgranaten und so. Mehrere Tage äh in Istanbul angegriffen. Äh entsprechend auch mein geringes Verständnis,
für Ministerpräsident Erdogan oder Präsident Erdogan oder was auch immer ähm von dem,
dieser Kampf gegen einen aufgeklärte ähm.
Bevölkerung in der Türkei ausgeht und in dieser Tradition, ich in dessen, in dieser Tradition sehe ich auch die Entwicklung in der Türkei, ja? Also das war das eine große Aufbäum der intellektuellen der Liberalen in der Türkei, die wurden
wirklich mit einer Brutalität, die ich,
an keiner anderen Stelle gesehen habe und ich hab in Demonstrationsgewalt durchaus schon in verschiedenen Ländern gesehen das war somit das,
heftigste was ich gesehen habe wie ein Aufstand eben niedergeschmettert wurde,
Und seitdem war da auch das war dann auch dieses mehr oder weniger das Ende der Bewegung. Und in dieser Tradition sieht man das jetzt. Ähm eine sehr schöne Aspekt. Ich sehe das gerade schon.
Gibt auch Unterstützer, wo man's gar nicht so erwartet hätte, ne? Also wenn sogar Boris Becker sich jetzt hier unterstützend äh für den neuen Sultan äußert, dann fragt man sich, was ist denn im Internet los.
Boris Becker twitterte dann irgendwie, ähm wann war das? Das war kannst du etwas hochscrollen, wann das, wann das genau war, das ja auch schon wieder ein paar Wochen her. Wir.
Dem Tweet steht vor fünfzehn Minut.
Ja, das ist klar, weil das ein Screenshot ist, Tim. Bisschen medienkompeten,
Fünfzehnter dritter, fünfzehnter dritter in twitterte, dass Boris Becker irgendwie Nazi Almania, also Nazi-Deutschland, Nazi-Hollander, Nazi-Holland.
Und dann äh das wusste ich auch mal, was da stand, aber irgendwie sowas wie,
wir werden wir sehen uns am sechzehnten April oder sowas, ne? Oder wir sehen uns beim Referendum oder so. Da,
hatten ein paar offenbar türkische Hacker, wenn die sich glaube ich auch als irgendwie als die türkische ja irgendwie sich ähm.
Volksfront von.
Nee, die haben sich noch irgendwie äh im Bekennerschreiben dazu, ne.
Türkische Volksfront.
Die hatten,
Eine große Anzahl an Twitter-Accounts unter ihrer Kontrolle gebracht und da ist auch nochmal ganz äh lehrreich oder vielleicht interessant für einige, wie sie das denn getan haben. Und zwar gab es eine,
Twitter-App mit dem Namen The Counter, die gibt's auch heute noch. Und da kann man sich ähm quasi so anmelden. Das habt ihr sicherlich schon öfter mal gesehen, dass ihr dann irgendwie sagt,
dass man, wenn man jetzt so auf seinem,
iPhone oder auf seinem Android irgendwie eine Nicht-Twitter-Applikation runterlehnt oder auch den Twitter-Applikation, dass man die autorisieren muss und dann steht da irgendwie ähm,
Tweet Bot kann Nachrichten schreiben, DMs lesen, hast du nicht gesehen und dann sag, da muss man sein Passwort eingeben, okay. Und dann hat diese Applikation.
Mit einem mit mehreren Offentication Togens, einem, der die Applikation ausweist, einen, der diese für diese Nutzer gilt, ähm Zugriff auf diesen Twitter-Account,
Und kann dann die Twitter-API bedienen und zwar dauerhaft. Deswegen können wir unsere Apps dann nutzen,
Es gibt aber auch so schöne Zusatzapps, die dann irgendwie so sowas wie äh The Counter hier in diesem Fall, die irgendwelche
Statistiken oder Analysen
für dich machen, die also die Twitter AP fragen, okay, wie viele Leute, wie viele neue Follower in dieser Woche, wie viele Retweets insgesamt, äh wie viele hast du nicht gesehen? Wie viel aus welchen Ländern kommen meine Follower, als solche Statistiken, also dann ermöglichen und dafür eben Abi-Zugriff brauchen.
Und weil die so weil die dann ähm in der Regel man kann das Granula machen, dass man sagt, ich will auch nur Lesezugriff auf Tweets oder sowas, ne? Oder ich will nur die Follower sehen. Man kann da natürlich auch sagen, ich möchte auch twittern. Und meistens wollen diese Dienste dann auch twittern, um sich nämlich selber zu bewerben. Das sieht man auch häufig
ähm
also wenn man solche Leute nicht sofort entfolgt, ähm dann sieht man das häufig, dass dann irgendwie so getwittert wird. In dieser Woche hatte ich fünfhundert Retweets und
dreihundert neue Follower.
War der Geilste.
Gucke auch du unter, haste nicht gesehen, Shady Punkt Ru äh und lasse dir eine schöne Statistik geben. Einen solchen Dienst haben offenbar sehr viele Leute genutzt, unter anderem auch Boris Becker,
und dann wurde dieser Dienst gehack
Und dann wurden da nämlich einmal alle diese Aufenthaltion Talkans rausgeholt und dann konnten die Angreifer eben schön mit diesen Aufenthaltion Talkens,
der Twitter API dann eben sagen hallo, jetzt nehme ich diesen Talk und jetzt bin ich Bochis Becker und äh und wittere das hier und der Wein also noch viele andere dabei, ne?
Ich habe das dann auch mal zum Anlass genommen, mal meine meine Twitter außer Resations mal durchzuschauen.
Da wirst du auch anders geworden, ne? Die akumulieren sich dabei und.
War nämlich auch dabei, aber ich glaube, ich hatte den irgendwie nur Rit Only,
Ähm und habe dann aber dann auch nochmal so ein paar alte äh so Analyticsdinger aus den frühen frühen Twitterzeiten, als das Internet noch ein äh eine grüne, eine grüne Wiese war,
Kühe friedlich ohne von irgendwelchen äh Türken mit Orangen beworfen zu werden äh Grasten,
und na ja, das schaltet man einfach mal alles ab.
Ja also schon noch kurz hingucken, weil ähm wenn man alles rausnimmt, dann muss man sich auch überall neu einloggen, ist aber auch nicht verkehrt, das einfach mal zu machen.
Ja, geht aber leider auch nicht so einfach. Also man kann zwar das meiste Revoken, aber es gibt so bestimmte aus Hentications, die man irgendwie nur über die App selber lösen kann. Ich habe nicht verstanden, warum das nicht auch serverseitig gehen sein äh gehen soll
verfangen uns in Details und eigentlich geht's ja hier um Spionage in Deutschland der Türkei, um mal vielleicht einen Anfang wieder zurückzukommen,
Das ist natürlich ein Problem und jetzt müssen wir mal gucken äh,
Was das so für Schockwellen im Geheimdienstapparat und vor allem auch über unsere Regierung äh liefert. Wobei so ein bisschen den Eindruck gehab
Vor September lehnt sich hier irgendwie keiner mehr so richtig aus dem Balkon.
Den Link zum Kontrollieren eurer Applikation machen wir auch noch in die Shownotes. Empfehle ich gerade mal.
Wir linken mal direkt in euren Account rein.
Kann man tatsächlich, ihr müsst dann eingeloggt sein, aber so.
Ja ist ganz normal, ist nicht weil wir so geile Hacker sind. Obwohl wir so geile Hacker haben.
Yes. Ich glaube, damit können wir die Türkei erstmal ähm abhaken oder soweit. Also kommen wir ja eh schon länger, aber wir machen das jetzt hier auch und äh setzen mal was durch.
Die Bundesregierung möchte auch gerne was durchsetzen und wie das so ist, wenn man was durchsetzen will, dann macht man einen.
Netzwerkdurchsetzungsgesetz.
Und äh das hatten wir in, das haben wir.
Mal so ein Podcast-Durchsetzungsgesetz machen, das wäre vielleicht auch mal was.
Wir könnten auch eine ganze Menge durchsetzen, aber der Tag ist noch jung.
Ne, damit sich das mal richtig durchsetzt. Da haben ja manche Leute wirklich zweifelt, weißt du? Oder einen Edblocker Durchsetzungsgesetz.
Das Netzwerkdurchsetzungsgesetz, da sollte sich das war von Heiko Maas herabgereicht worden ähm und um das Problem mit dem mit diesem Hate Speech zu lösen. Ähm.
Und,
dann sah das auch erstmal irgendwie so halbwegs vernünftig aus, die Verbände und Interessenvertreter fingen an ihre Stellungnahmen zu diesem ersten Entwurf zu schreiben und dann ähm da gab's auch eine Frist
Bis wann man die Antworten erwarten würde und still und leise veröffentlichte das Justizministerium dann eine überarbeitete Version.
Und legte diese überarbeitete Version dann auch direkt einfach mal ohne weitere Absprache der EU-Kommission zur Notifikation vor. Äh Notifikation heißt vom
also so hier so übrigens zu beabsichtigen wie das zu machen. Schaut euch das schon mal an, ne? Damit ihr Bescheid wisst.
Und da wird dieses Netzwerkdurchsetzungsgesetz äh in dieser zweiten Version
ein bisschen geändert. Und zwar kommen jetzt neben irgendwelchen Beleidigungen, Persönlichkeitsrechtsverletzungen noch das Sexualstrafrecht mit hinzu,
Was überrascht, weil
Das Detektieren von Nippeln ja zu einer der höchsten Fähigkeiten von Facebook gehört, die ähm die also man könnte jetzt nicht sagen, dass in diesem Bereich des Sexualstrafrechtes die sozialen Netzwerke,
besondere Probleme hätten. Den Vorgaben des äh des Gesetzgebers in Deutschland äh zu entsprechen.
Wobei ja Facebook schon Probleme hat, männliche und weibliche Nippel auseinanderzahl.
Ja, wenn man kein Gesicht dazu ist. Ja, also genau, kann man nochmal, kann man noch dran arbeiten? Ähm.
Ja, ist schwierig. Ähm das machen wir alles mit künstlicher Intelligenz.
Es verlangt jetzt keine wirksamen Maßnahmen mehr gegen die erneute Speicherung des Rechtswidrigen Inhaltes. Ähm was man erstmal ganz wahrscheinlich als also,
Das bedeutet würde jedem also das, das betrifft eigentlich den Fall des jungen Syrers, der ja gesagt hatte, ich möchte
nicht nur, dass das gelöscht wird, sondern ich möchte auch, dass mein Bild in diesem Zusammenhang auch in Zukunft nicht mehr genutzt werden kann. Und für den sah es ja ähm erstmal nicht so gut aus. Aber das sollte also gemacht werden, dass man diesen Anspruch hat. Das wurde aber wiederum aus dem Netzwerkdurchsetzungsgesetz in der zweiten Version gestrichen,
Und dann kam die dritte Änderung und die lautete folgendermaßen, dass in Paragraph
Vierzehn Absatz zwei des Telemediengesetzes nach dem Wort Eigentum die Wörter oder anderer absolut geschätzter, geschützter Rechte eingefügt werden. Und ich hatte ja vor einigen Folgen schon mal erklärt, ähm wie so,
Dass sich hinter sowas dann in der Regel, da sind die die Schätzchen versteckt, ne? Und wenn man diesen Satz dann einmal anschaut.
Das Telemediengesetz regelt ja die Haftung von Providern und Postern und zwar sämtlichen,
nicht nur irgendwie soziale Netzwerke und Twitter, sondern sämtlich, also auch Meterebene Punkt ME fällt unter das Telemediengesetz
Und das ist äh schon eine ganz andere Hausnummer. Also bei TMG sollten da die ersten roten Lampen angehen und dann schaut man sich den Paragraph vierzehn an, denn hier steht ja in diesem Satz steht ja gar nicht, womit der
Paragraph vierzehn überhaupt zu tun hat, der Paragraph vierzehn regelt die Herausgabe von Bestandsdaten.
Und ähm Bestandsdaten sind also bei,
die diejenigen, die sich nicht ändern in Abgrenzung von Verkehrsdaten. Du hast also jetzt irgendwie so eine wir bieten hier ein, du bietest ein Telemediendienst an, sagen wir mal, der heißt,
Meterebene Community oder weil irgendwas, ne, du, du bietest irgendeine Seite an. Und man kann sich da registrieren,
So, da könnte also du, du verlangst von deinen Nutzern, dass sie ihren Namen und ihre E-Mail-Adresse angeben,
Das sind dann Bestandsdaten der Nutzer. Und ähm deren Herausgabe ist eigentlich nur sehr eingeschränkt erlaubt, etwa an die Polizei,
oder zur Abwehr von Gefahren des internationalen Terrorismus an die Geheimdienste. Unter diesen Umständen musst du Bestands eine Bestandsdatenauskunft machen.
Registriert, E-Mail-Adresse ist.
Jetzt habe ich das auf Meterebene bezogen und sagte ihr Name äh und E-Mail. Ich habe aber gerade gesagt, dass Themen Medien äh Gesetz gilt auch für Provider. Und diese Bestandsdatenauskunft ist wie Fail Shara, nämlich,
vor den Kadi gezerrt werden, wohlgemerkt nicht von Polizei oder Geheimdiensten, sondern von Zivilisten, nämlich Abmahnkanzleien. Wenn eine Verletzung geistigen Eigentums stattgefunden hat.
Ähm das ist eine Ausnahme, sonst also nur an ähm Polizei oder Geheimdienste und eben zur Durchsetzung der Rechte am geistigen Eigentum,
an Anwaltskanzleien. Die können also dann sagen hier, wir wollen das auch haben und dann kriegen die Bike diesen Kram, diesen Prozess haben wir mal länger und ausführlich erläutert, ähm als es um diese,
als Porno ab meiner Recubeabmahnung, der das Thema waren, aber auch die Ausweitung der Bestandsdatenauskunft. So, das.
Das heißt, Bestandsdatenauskunft ist in den meisten Fällen, wo sie zur Anwendung kommt, ein D-Maskieren der IP-Adresse
Wenn wir also bei Metaebene Punkt ME einen Besuch von euch bekommen und ihr einen Podcast runterladet, dann sehen wir die IP-Adresse.
Und wir können maximal damit irgendwie ein Haus nehmen, raussuchen und sehen dann, bei welchem Provider ihr seid. Mehr können wir da in der Regel nicht
sehen. Oder bei welchem VPN ihr seid oder so was. Aber wir können nicht einfach sehen, ah da ist hier, ne? Ähm,
ähm wie heißt der Karl Mustermann oder wie nennt man den Max Mustermann heißt er in Deutschland, ne? Max Mustermann in John Do äh und John Doe oder so. Das können wir nicht.
Erika muss dauern.
Dafür müssten wir ähm Polizei oder Geheimdienst sein oder Abmahner zur Durchsetzung unserer,
unseres geistigen, unser Recht haben eigentlich geistigen Eigentum. So, das heißt, bei Strafrecht wird das gehoben und bei beim geistigen Eigentum, ansonsten hast du die Pseudonymität durch IP,
Und durch diese Änderung wird die Bestandsdatenauskunft nun auch bei Persönlichkeitsrechtsverletzungen,
oder bei Verletzung anderer absolut geschätzter, geschützter Rechte möglich. Und das auch noch ohne,
Richter vorbehalten. Dann fragt man sich, was sind denn andere absolut geschützte Rechte? Ja, die das Persönlichkeitsrecht oder die im Materialgüterrecht und dazu gehört zum Beispiel ähm das Recht am,
eingerichteten oder ausgeübten Gewerbebetrieb,
Schreibt uns, ähm, der Jörg Heiderich auf Heise DE in einer ausführlichen Analyse und sagt,
Was da passieren könnte, ist also, dass unter anderem Unternehmen,
verschädigenden Werturteilen oder abträglichen wahren Tatsachen geschützt werden mit diesen Recht. Und da könnten sie dann, wenn wir jetzt hier so über Bewertungsportale reden, könnte das Ruck zuck gehen.
Dass die sich ähm ganz schnell mal eben über eine Abmahnung eine Bestandsdatenauskunft machen,
und sofort irgendwie Leute, die negative Beurteilungen geschrieben haben,
dann da irgendwie anschreiben. Oder er schreibt im Worst Case Fall. Kann man sich so recht bequem die Adressen der politischen Gegner vom Internetanbieter kostenfrei nach Hause schicken lassen,
So oder so. Wir sehen da in dieser klitzekleinen Ausnahme, die wir bisher haben mit geistigem Eigentum,
die auch schon sehr schlecht ist, weil sie zu nichts Gutem in unserer Gesellschaft führt. Ähm,
sondern sondern einfach nur sehr, sehr viel Geld diesen Abmahnkanzleien bringt, die inzwischen diese Prozesse durchautomatisiert haben und einfach mal nur eine Gelddruckmaschine sind,
Ja, also das kannst du von vorne bis hinten mit ein bisschen peifen und durchoptimieren. Dann brauchst du noch jemanden, der dir der die Dinger, die hinten am Drucker rausfallen, kuvertiert und und die Briefmarke draufklebt, ne?
Das gibt's auch schon fertig als Service.
Gibt's auch schon fertig? Also das kannst du Auto kannst du wirklich in einem Wisch durchmachen, dieser Meinungskram. Die könnten jetzt hier ähm eine eine anwachsen ihres Geschäftsmodells um ein Vielfaches,
beklatschen, wenn dieses Gesetz so durchkommt. Und dagegen sind so viele, dass sogar der Bitcom dagegen ist. Der Bitcoin sagt,
Der Branchenverband Bitcoin sagt schon jetzt ist es so, äh, dass kleine Anbieter in voraus allen Gehorsam in in Sorge, rechtlicher Folgen, ähm, schon,
Vorlöschen, also es nicht drauf ankommen lassen und damit eben die sogenannten Chilling-Effekts eintreten. Und
Wenn man dann so eine Debatte führt, als hätte man nichts kein kein Beispiel zur Hand, liefert YouTube dann auch noch direkt eins und hat heute dann ein Video der Band Slime von ihrer Seite gelöscht, die sich dort gegen den Rechtsruck in Deutschland wendet. Das Video ähm.
Wohlgemerkt von ihrer eigenen YouTube Präsenz. Ja. Mhm. Von.
Von ihrer eigenen wegen Hate Speech,
Ja, kannst nicht machen. Kannst jetzt nicht einfach so eine so Bevölkerungsgruppen hier beschimpfen, ne? All die, die nur dumm. Also, dass die in diesem Video ist, geht's also gegen,
den Rechtsruck in Deutschland ähm
und das ist eben als von als Hate Speech jetzt von YouTube gelöscht worden. Man kann wahrscheinlich davon ausgehen, dass einfach ein paar
Leute, die mit dem Inhalt des Videos nicht fallen. Nicht zufrieden waren, massiv da einfach drauf geklickt haben anstößiger Inhalt, Hate Sweet und YouTube dann irgendwann automatisch gelöscht hat und man kann nur hoffen, dass es dann irgendwann auch wieder.
Dort erscheinen wird.
Tja, also das ist, das sieht gar nicht so gut aus, was da mit dem Netzwerkdurchsetzungsgesetz stattfinden soll. Ursprünglich geplant, als eine Idee, irgendwie die sozialen Netzwerke, den sozialen Netzwerken Beine zu machen, ähm dass sie irgendwie auf ein halbwegs gesitteten Auseinandersetzung bei sich wert legen. Inzwischen also
das, was der Jörg Heiderich so schön als Atombombe oder nuklearen Erstschlag bezeichnet. Ein Frontalangriff auf das Vertrauen im Internet.
Und ähm,
dass der Justizminister einerseits erst diese eine Variante des Gesetzes zur zum zum Kommentieren
herausgibt. Und dann ähm eine still und heilig, eine zweite Version veröffentlicht und die dann der EU-Kommission freulich, das bezeichnet Jörg Heidrich als
grobes Foul. Denke, das kann man so auch sagen.
Stehen lassen. Tja.
Gut, so viel zum Durchsetzungs äh Gesetz, damit sich diese Netzwerke endlich mal durchsetzen.
Der E-Zeit. Ähm zu Terror.
Terror, ja, das wollte ich auch einfach nochmal mit mit Überraschung nimmt man ja zur Kenntnis.
Was immer alles so rauskommt, nachdem irgendwie mal was passiert ist und ein paar Wochen.
Wer da mal so ein paar Wochen vergangen sind, wenn dann alle schon eine Ausweitung der Überwachung und was nicht alles gefordert haben, stellt sich dann raus.
Dass das äh Nordrhein-Westfälische Landeskriminalamt, das Düsseldorfer Innenministerium bereits im März zweitausendsechzehn. Also lange vor dem ähm,
Attentat auf dem Berliner Weihnachtsmarkt durch eines Amri gewarnt hat vor diesem ähm Menschen und seine Abschiebung angeregt hat
Da fragt man sich, Mensch, Merch, März zweitausendsechzehner sind zwischen ein Jahr her, so lange schon ähm ist, ist dieser Typ aktenkundig. Und das LKA hat sogar seine Abschiebung beim Innenministerium ähm,
angeregt, wie kamen die denn darauf? Ja, stellt sich raus
Der wurde seit Dezember zweitausendfünfzehn telefonisch überwacht. Denn eine Vertrauensperson des LKA NRW.
Die sich in der islamistischen Szene rumtreibt, meldete am siebzehnten November zweitausendfünfzehn,
Das zum ähm zum Umfeld von Abu Walaa, auch ein junger Mann mit dem Namen Anis gehöre. Und dann wurde er eben seit jetzt im
quasi ne, zwei Wochen später, Dezember zweitausendfünfzehn begann die telefonische Überwachung.
Im Rahmen dieser telefonischen Überwachung haben LKA-Ermittler dann auch Anis Amris Kommunikation über das verschlüsselte Chatprogramm Telegram,
mitverfolgt.
Mindestens von sich behauptet, gut verschlüsselt zu sein, aber ich.
Da komme ich gleich nochmal ganz kurz zu. Da haben wir das nehme ich, der kommen wir gleich gleich zu ihr nur im im zweiten Februar zweitausendsechzehn haben sie also schon bei Telegram dem als sicher und verschlüsselt geltenden Messenger
mitbekommen, dass er äh in Deutschland eine Schwester heiraten wolle und äh das ist wohl irgendwie bekanntermaßen eine.
Ein Begriff dafür, dass man ein äh Selbstwortanschlag begehen möchte. Und das wurde im Innenministerium auch mitgeteilt, das Innenministerium hat das ignoriert in Ministerium NRW,
Ähm ja, das ist doch ärgerlich. Ihr wollt also wir kriegen hier irgendwie die Forderung nach mehr Überwachung rein.
Und da stellt sich raus, dass der Typ seit zwanzig seit zweitausendfünfzehn auf dem Radar war, alle Hinweise da waren und eben ignoriert wurden. Das finde ich dann schon mal allerhand,
Dann würde ich noch ganz kurz auf die Sache mit Telegram eingehen. Ähm das hatten wir wahrscheinlich hier auch als Thema behandelt. Und zwar,
ja ähm aber um sicher zu gehen, erkläre ich das nochmal. Und.
Ist ja nicht so, als würden wir uns hier weigern, uns zu wiederholen. Ähm und zwar,
Was da bei Telegram abgehört wurde, war ein Gruppenchat. Und die Gruppenchats bei Telegram sind,
nicht ähm verschlüsselt oder nicht vernünftig verschlüsselt. Und was da, was man da macht in diesem Rahmen, jetzt muss ich kurz überlegen, ob ich das noch richtig in Erinnerung habe.
Man registriert quasi ein neues Gerät.
Bei Telegram. Und das kannst du machen, wenn du unter Kontrolle der Telefonnummer bist. Du sagst jetzt irgendwie, hey, ich habe hier ein weiteres Handy, mit dem möchte ich Telegramm unter dieser Nummer nutzen,
die Verifikation, die Telegram dann durchführt, ähm, findet über,
SMS statt. Schick deine SMS dahin und sagt, wenn dieser Code hier drin ist, dann akzeptieren wir deinen Apitoken auch für diesen Nutzer.
Und dann ähm schmeißt du das andere Gerät, was der, was deine Zielperson eigentlich nutzt. Schmeißt du dann raus.
Wird nicht zusätzlich gemacht, sondern es ist.
Nee, schmeißt du raus, damit sich das neu registriert. Dann kriegt das nämlich keine Warnung, dass du als zweites Gerät registriert bist,
sondern es ist das neu registrierte Gerät. Also es ist der Fehler, den Telegram an der Stelle macht, ist, dass es nicht immer alle warnt,
Alle Geräte waren, dass es ein neues gibt. Ähm merkt man zum Beispiel, also ich kenne das nur von von Apple, wenn du jetzt irgendwie ein neues, einen neuen Apple Rechner zum Beispiel,
Führ dein I Message.
Dich da einloggst, dann kommt überall.
Dann kommt auf allen Geräten, auf dem Handy, auf den anderen Laptops und dein Mac und was steht dann? Es wurde ein neues Gerät registriert. Genau das hat Telegram nicht gemacht,
beziehungsweise und man muss dazu auch noch sagen, welcher alle bisher schon registriert sind,
Ja, das macht Apple übrigens auch nicht, aber Fakt ist, man kann sich so relativ einfach eines Telegram-Accounts bemächtigen, wenn man in der Lage ist,
Zustellen einer SMS abzufangen und das sind ja Strafverfolgungsbehörden in Deutschland. Und.
Deswegen konnten sie das so schön machen und es ist gerade Teil einer anderen Auseinandersetzung, also diese Praxis wurde,
vor mehreren Monaten schon geliegt, ähm fand da im Rahmen eines Ermittlungsverfahren gegen so eine Nazigrupierung ähm,
Tim registriert hier gerade ein neues Gerät.
Nein, das ist ein Tourfactor aus Citication Login. Ich wollte gerade mal gucken, o.
Okay. Wolltest gerade mal gucken, was ich so alles bei dir schon angemeldet habe. Ähm.
Ob ich sehe, was schon alles angemeldet ist.
Diese,
Diese Methode ist aber auch zumindest fragwürdig, die da zur Anwendung kommt, rechtlich. Ähm weil die die Erlaubnis, die die,
Strafverfolgungsbehörden in diesem Zusammenhang haben ist ja erstmal nur äh TKÜ und nicht Quellen TKÜ,
Und so haben sie also quasi einen aktiven Eingriff in einen Messenger, der da stattfindet und ähm,
Das ist noch Subtecto Discussion, inwiefern das wirklich
rechtlich gedeckt ist. Ich würde sagen, nein ist nicht rechtlich gedeckt, was sie da getan haben, aber man kennt auch irgendwie so ungefähr meine meine Tendenz, wie ich damit umgehe, wenn äh Strafverfolgungsbehörden,
So etwas, kann man vielleicht auch anders sehen. Ich bin gespannt auf die ähm,
Position der Richter. Aber ich denke, Anis Amri sollte also an dieser Stelle für keinerlei Ausweitung.
Von Überwachung ähm und und irgendwelchen Zitisbemühungen herhalten, denn hier haben wir ganz eindeutig einfach ein wunderschön dokumentiertes, reines Versagen der Ermittler und Behörden und Verantwortlichen,
Genau, man kann sich hierbei ähm bei Apple offenbar auch seine ganzen Geräte anschauen und Tim, ich muss sagen, das ist ein bisschen viel bei dir.
Findest du? Ja. Ach, da geht noch was.
Ja, da geht noch was, ne.
Na ja, ist halt meine Geräte. Tja. Wer hat der hat?
Ja, wer hat ja? Ja, aber gut. Alles klar.
Alles klar. Alles total sicher Heidibus.
Also solche Sicherheits und das um das mal vielleicht ganz kurz ähm mal in Abgrenzung zu Signal zu erklären, weil es dann eh die Frage in den Kommentaren kommt. Ähm.
Eine Güte heute habe ich es aber. Telegram ähm.
Auch schon spät am Morgen.
Es ist spät am Morgen, genau. Normalerweise sind wir um diese Uhrzeit schon wieder im Bett. Ähm.
Fertig.
Telegram hat ein Key Pro Gerät. Das heißt, wenn man jetzt zwei Geräte bei Telegram registriert, dann ähm und dann einen sicheren Chat anfängt, dann kann man den auch immer nur von dem Gerät schicken,
Und aus diesem Grunde diese Gruppenchats funktionieren aber auf allen Geräten und sind eben einfach nicht verschlüsselt. Was tatsächlich,
Muss man einfach sagen, Strafverfolgungs- und Sicherheitsbehörden in Deutschland über lange Zeit große Vorteile beim Auskundschaften von äh islamistischen und rechtsradikalen ähm.
Gruppen verschafft hat, weil diese aus welchem Grund auch immer auf diesem Messenger stehen.
Andere Messenger machen das eben anders und haben vernünftige Multiparty ähm Incription mit Efamerial Kies oder sonst was. Wenn man einen Gruppenchat aufmacht. Telegram hat das eben nicht.
Ich ich weich.
Alle netzpolitischen Aspekte dieser Meldungen abgedeckt zu haben.
Muss irgendwann mal überlegen, ob wir nicht noch irgendwie so einen Security-Podcast macht. Eigentlich viel.
Ich glaube das könnte einiges entspannen.
Ich mache ja Netzpolitik nur als Hobby.
Wir lassen die Hörer abstimmen.
So, dann haben wir ähm kommen wir jetzt in den Bereich der kürzeren Meldungen, Tim. Du, ich sage dir das nur nochmal, weil du, wenn ich dir das nicht sage, dann stellst du immer so gemeine Fragen. Bei den Themen, die ich nicht so gut vorbereitet habe.
Ach so, ich soll komplett das Maul halten, saß er.
Also es gibt ein ein neues Datenschutzgesetz, das DS an Puck.
Das Datenschutzgesetz, Anpassungs und irgendwas Gesetz,
Ähm denn ab Mai zweitausendachtzehn muss ja die Datenschutzgrundverordnung angewendet werden, die ja relativ weitreichende Vorgaben macht. Wir erinnern uns ja an die Datenschutz,
Grundverordnung und vor einem Dreivierteljahr gab es dann schon den ersten Entwurf und entsprechende Leaks, wie Deutschland, der in seinem Bundesdatenschutz,
Gesetz. Ah du, ich, es lackert gerade ähm anpassen möchte und die EU ähm Richtlinie umsetzen möchte, daher das U noch im Namen Datenschutz, Anpassungs und Umsetzungs,
Gesetz EU. Das ist erstmalig vor vor viel vor einem dreiviertel Jahr geliegt und seitdem setzen sich die Datenschützer mit dem äh,
DS Anpuck auseinander und ähm da gab's jetzt eine Sachverständigenanhörung.
Und das war irgendwie äh die war in dieser Woche und dann gibt's ein ausführliches Protokoll bei Netzpolitik Orkich. Ähm zitiere da größtenteils draus.
Und die die dort geladenen Sachverständigen haben relativ viele äh Kritikpunkte gefunden und ähm der Hauptkritikpunkt waren also die betroffenen Rechte, also die Rechte derjenigen deren Daten, die irgendwo verarbeitet werden
Und die ähm die Koalition kam dann irgendwie kurz vor Beginn der Sitzung,
mit einem Änderungsantrag vorbei, der der ähm dann im Teil der dann Teil der Abstimmung am Donnerstag sein sollen würde,
Was ein bisschen respektlos gegenüber den Sachverständigen ist, die man sich zu so einer Anhörung lädt ähm und natürlich auch ein bisschen respektlos gegenüber der äh,
der anderen Parteien, mit denen man da gemeinsam sitzt. Konstantin von Notz hat sich da zu Recht ähm lauthals beschwert, dass unter solchen
Bedingungen eben eine seriöse Arbeit des Bundestages in der Gesetzgebung einfach nicht durchgeführt werden kann.
Ich zitiere ein paar äh der Kritikpunkte und Verweise ansonsten auf den Artikel bei Netzpolitik Org und die Stellungnahme von Peter Schar, dem ehemaligen Bundesdatenschutzbeauftragten, der natürlich hier dann entsprechend
wahrscheinlich, den man hier eine sehr fundierte
Kompromisslose Meinung glaube ich zugestehen kann. Also wichtig war die Beschränkung der Betroffenen Rechte, dass man nämlich ähm die,
ähm die Informationspflichten der Datenverarbeitenden, sowie die Löschrechte der Betroffenen,
einschränken sollte. Es ist so, wenn jemand über euch Daten verarbeitet, dann könnt ihr da einfach hingehen und sagen, hier, ich wünsche Auskunft über diese Daten und ich beantrage, ich verlange deren Löschung.
Und das ähm muss muss die Datenverarbeitung der Institutionen dann eben auch tun. Kann man bei jedem machen. Macht manchmal auch Spaß
Ich hab das vor vielen Jahren mal beim Springer Verlag gemacht und dann irgendwie den ganz versehentlich darüber bei Netzpolitik Org berichtet und dann wurde gegen mich ein Ermittlungsverfahren wegen ähm Computersabotage angestrengt
weil die Springer in Boxen auf einmal voll waren von Datenschutzanfragen.
Ich glaube, das hatten wir ja auch seit der Zei.
Das ist aber es ist schon wieder viele Jahre her. Ähm Ende vom Lied war, dass die Ärger bekommen haben im Berliner Datenschutz, weil sie äh weil sie irgendwie
sich geweigert haben, diese diese Anfragen zu beantworten und meine auch irgendwie nicht ordnungsgemäß verantwortlich haben. Aber es ist eine andere Geschichte. Also man kann Auskunftsverfahren man kann Auskunft verlangen und man kann ein Löschrecht in Anspruch nehmen. Und hier gab es dann in diesen
Im DSN-Bruch gab's eine Einschränkung, dass das nicht,
Der Fall wäre, wenn das einen unverhältnismäßig hohen Aufwand bedeuten würde. Für die datenverarbeitende Stelle. Und ich kann mir oder ihre allgemein anerkannten Geschäftszwecke
gefährden würde. Bei diesen in diesem allgemein anerkannten Geschäftsfeken da sehe ich sowas wie wie die Schufa, ne?
Bei der Schufa muss man eigentlich für eine Auskunft bezahlen. Man kann aber einmal im Jahr eben im Rahmen des Datenschutzrechts da eine Anfrage stellen und da könnte ich mir natürlich vorstellen, dass das ihre allgemein anerkannten Geschäftszwecke gefährden würde, wenn es auf einmal alle machen würden,
dass das natürlich für die Schufe ein unverhältnismäßig hoher Aufwand ist, ne? Beispiel jetzt.
Der Änderungsantrag, der dann eben auch eingebracht wurde, schränkt das daher auf wenige Gründe ein, um Kleinunternehmen zu schützen, damit die nicht,
darunter leiden. Äh Andrea Vossof monierte, dass ihre Durchsetzungsbefugnisse gegenüber Justiz und Polizei auf das unverbindliche Instrument der Beanstandung begrenzt sind,
ja? Also wir haben das ja schon häufig hier kritisiert, Andrea Voss, auch Vossov, die Bundesdatenschutzbeauftragte, wenn die irgendwie Probleme hat, Mist mit Justuz, Justiz oder Polizei oder auch dem BRD in Bad Deiblingen besucht, dann darf sie
das Niederschreiben und beanstanden,
dann darf sie das auf ihrer auf ihrem Blog oder was veröffentlichen und die darf das auch ausdrucken und die darf das auch dahin schicken
und die dürfen das dann auch zur Kenntnis nehmen und dann hat sich das. Denn sie hat einfach keinerlei ähm,
rechtliche Hand habe, da er zu irgendeiner Durchsetzung zu führen. Die dürfen das zur Kenntnis nehmen und die dürfen das ignorieren und das hat keine Konsequenzen. Und die EU-Vorgabe verlang.
Sie hat schon äh äh das Recht auf ein ein umfassendes und nachdrückliches Aussprechen eines.
Ja und das und das, sie hat auch das Recht auf Kenntnisnahme,
so wie jeder andere Mensch auch. Aber wenn die EU-Vorgabe verlangt, eben, dass ein Datenschutzbeauftragte ähm mehr kann nämlich, sie muss eine gerichtliche Klärung erwirken können.
Und das kann sie eben nicht. So, sie kann im Moment beanstanden, dann wird das gelesen, gelacht, gelocht und abgeheftet. Und ähm dann ist gut.
Aber sie sagt, sie möchte die Möglichkeit haben und das ist, denke ich, sehr wichtig, dass eine, dass also gerichtlich, dass ein Gesetzverstoß,
Gesetzverstoß, ein Verstoß gegen das Bundesdatenschutzgesetz, auch irgendwie gerichtlich geklärt werden kann, wenn er von äh Justiz oder Polizei begangen wird.
Und ähm weiterhin steht hier, das finde ich, ist noch viel witziger. Äh sie dürfen sich im nach diesem neuen Gesetz nicht mehr proaktiv mit Stellungnahmen an Institutionen wenden, sondern nur wenn sie gefragt wird.
Das ist gut.
Und damit ist sie, damit ist die Unabhängigkeit dann halt auch wirklich hinüber. Äh also da ist.
Ja. Also wow, das ist gut. Das äh das müsste man mal bei der Polizei einführen.
Also ich, wer hat sie denn gerufen.
Wie sie wollen mich jetzt hier für sie wollen mich für Einbruch festnehmen irgendwie. Ich habe sie doch gar nicht so aufgefordert.
Ich habe für kein.
Also da sind, da verstecken sich noch ein paar Scherze drin, ne.
Meine Herren, ey, wer kommt denn auf sowas?
Dann gibt's doch das Konzept der kontrollfreien Räume. Ähm,
Äh und zwar verlieren Datenschutzbeauftragte offenbar den Anspruch ähm
Krankenhäuser, Arzt und Tierarztpraxen, Anwalts und Notariatskanzleien, Apotheken, Steuerberatungs- und Buchführungsbüro oder Suchtberatungsstellen zu betreten, um vor Ort die Datenverarbeitung zu prüfen,
Ähm jetzt kann ich natürlich verstehen, dass man sagt, ja okay, hier, ne? Also ein Tierarzt, der, der,
Der steht aber unter besonderem Schutz, weil der ja ne.
Privatsphäre der Tiere sicherstellen muss.
Ja oder in den nehmen wir eine Suchtberatungsstelle. Aber ich denke mal, ich meine, wenn du einen an deine Daten gucken lassen kannst, dann ist das wahrscheinlich ein Datenschutzbeauftragt,
Und ähm gerade in diesen hoh, in dieser Verarbeitung der hochkritischen Daten, ne? Also Anwalt, äh Krankenhaus, ne? Da willst du doch vor Ort Prüfungen durch Datenschutzbeauftragte haben,
Also ist ja ganz klar oder also dass dass du genau da kontrollieren musst, wo kritische Daten sind. Buchführungsbüros, Steuerberatungskanzlei, ja, okay, Steuer beim Steuerberater sollen die vielleicht wegbleiben. Aber
Können ja meine anderen Steuern beim beim Steuerberater mache ich das ja schon. Aber ähm nee aber das ist doch, ist doch auch wieder ein Unding aus.
Welche Daten, auf welche Datenschutzbeauftragten bezieht sich denn das bezieht sich das jetzt auf die Länderbeauftragten, weil äh man also gut das sind jetzt alles keine
Ähm oder die meisten Organisationen oder die meisten Berufsgruppen, die du hier aufgezählt hast,
sehr eher so kleinere Gruppen, ne. Krankenhäuser wiederum, da kann's ja dann auch schon mal so Betriebsratgröße geben, womit auch äh.
Es geht um das diese Berufsgruppen, Kontrollbehörden Zutritt zu ihren Geschäftsräumen gewähren, beziehungsweise nicht gewähren müssen,
Also eine Kontrollbehörde. Schon äh Landesdatenschutzbeauftragter oder Bundesdatenschutz.
Okay, also jetzt nicht betriebseigene Datenschutzbeauftragte zum Beispiel et cetera.
Nein, nein, nein, die, nein, das schon. Ja, ja. Aber jetzt kommt der, kommt der Landesdatenschutzbeauftragte und sagt, hör mal, ihr macht doch hier was mit Daten.
So wie die Vorsorgt hier beim in Bad Aibling da irgendwie.
Immer damit und dann sagen die, die.
Tag. Wir wollen hier mal rein.
Krankenhaus. Bei Albi ist ein Krankenhaus.
Oder besucht Beratungsbestellung, was man auch nicht sowas ist vielleicht sind das neue Schlupfleich, was sie da irgendwie aufmachen. Ja, nee, wir sind hier alle, also wir beraten hier nur die.
Ne? Wenn du sagst, du hast.
Wir sind alle datensüchtig.
Wenn du sagst, du hast einen Daten, du hast ein wenn du sagst, du hast ein Datenschutzgesetz,
Und du hast eine Datenschutzbeauftragte Institution, Datenschutzbeauftragte der Datenschutzbeauftragte. Und du sagst denn ja, die dürfen aber äh wir haben erstens keinerlei juristische Mittel irgendwas zur Durchsetzung zu bringen.
Die Polizei denen hat sie nur was zu sagen, wenn die sie darum bitten
Und überall da, wo kritische Daten verarbeitet werden, darf die gar nicht rein,
Dann kannst du halt wirklich sagen, also was soll denn der noch den ganzen Tag machen, ne? Wir sitzen hier und da haben und machen Witze über Andrea Vosshof. Ja gut, die arme Frau. Was soll die machen? Kann Pressemitteilung schreiben in dem nächsten, ne? Also das ist wirklich ähm das ist wirklich
lächerlich. Und entsprechend wurde das dann eben auch.
Kritisiert. Aber soll ja eh morgen entschieden werden. Tim, insofern wahrscheinlich veröffentlichen wir auch erst morgen äh damit äh ist das jetzt schon wieder. Alles heute noch in den.
Alles hier. Das kommt alles heute noch aus der Tageshaltung lang.
Ja, stimmt. Na, ich kann's vergessen. Auch so eine Zeitze. Zeitzonenfrage gerade bei mir. So, dann ähm wo wir schon bei Datenherausgabe sind. Kurz. Ja.
Bei kurzem das war eine echte Kurzmeldung jetzt.
Ich sage das nur, damit du keine gemein falsch ist. Du hast trotzdem eine gestellt, hast.
Ja, so bin ich, das äh meine Rolle hier.
Ja, früh. Tim und ich Podcast gegeneinander, nicht miteinander.
Great Podcast, Battle, hast begonnen.
So, da haben wir hier Thelia, einen VPN-Provider in Schweden. Der wurde mal eben gerichtlich dazu verdonnert, rund achttausendsechshundert ähm IP-Adressen herauszugeben. Zahlreiche Kunden des Providers wurden nämlich Urheberrechtsverletzungen vorgeworfen.
Und die haben jetzt auch angekündigt, dem Urteil
Folge zu leisten. Und da auch hier haben wir, ne? E-Mail-Adresse, Telefonnummern und Postadresse der betroffenen Kunden. Also mit anderen Worten eine Bestandsdatenauskunft beim VPN Provider, weil eben offenbar,
Anonymisierungsdienst ähm äh genutzt wurde, u.
Heißt das hier, aber auch dann Lockweis haben, welche IP-Adressen sie, welchem Kunden zugeteilt haben.
Da ist natürlich genau der, der Punkt, wo auf den man bei einem VPM Provider achten muss, also eine E-Mail-Adresse kann der ja gerne haben
Wofür braucht denn der VPN-Provider, der mich anonymisieren soll, eine Telefonnummer oder eine Postadresse von mir?
Und ich habe auch nicht den Eindruck, dass ein VPN Provider unbedingt loggen muss, von welcher IP-Adresse er mich auf welche andere IP-Adresse umschaltet. Ähm es gibt,
VPN Provinder, die solche Daten nicht sammeln und ich halte es einfach ein Scherz, wenn ich mich beim VPN Provider anmelde, bei dem ich mich mit Bitcoin bezahlen kann.
Ja? Äh der ist so ein Witz. Also man, wenn man sich beim VPN Provider anbietet, äh, anmeldet, dann nimmt man eine eine temporäre Wegwerf-E-Mail-Adresse und zahlt ein Jahr im Voraus per Bitcoin,
So läuft das.
Wallet. Mhm.
Ja okay, aber das ist schon wieder eine ganz andere, das ist dann wieder ein ganz anderes Ding, ne? Außerdem wissen wir ja alle, wo wir anonym äh Bitcoins kaufen können. Ja klar.
Die erpressen wir einfach mit Redson Ware.
Ja gut, wie meint ihr, wir machen das hier alles zu Ome? Wir müssen auch gucken, dass irgendwie Brot auf.
Und gebratene Tomaten.
Also Vorsicht.
Dich.
Fuß. Also Achtung bitte bei der Auswahl eures äh VPN Providers
solche Daten sollen da einfach gar nicht anfallen, ne? Also da das das ist leider bei Daten, die die eine Weisheit was sie nicht hast, das kann der auch nicht weggenommen werden, ne.
So, dann haben wir noch weiteres Skurriles. Ähm die Bundesnetzagentur ähm hat sich jetzt an die äh Programmierer und Vertreiber von irgendwie einhundert bis einhundertfünfzig
Jabba Cliance äh gewendet und hat gesagt, sie wollen ähm,
gerne mal äh prüfen, ob diese im Rahmen des Telekommunikationsgesetzes einer Meldepflicht unterliegen oder nicht.
Bekannt wurde, dass durch den äh durch den Entwickler der Software Zaba ähm,
Und er hat also irgendwie diesen Brief bekommen und in Russland empfangen und hat dann irgendwie äh gefragt, ja ich habe ja so einen Brief bekommen, kann er irgendwie, ja, mal sagen wir, wie werde ich die denn los? Denn das Entscheidende ist, dass äh Jabba,
also mit anderen Worten, dass das XMP Protokoll ähm.
Und die Software, die dafür benutzt wird, natürlich zwei unterschiedliche Dinge sind. Also es gibt einmal den Jabba-Server, in dem,
auf dem der Dienst selber läuft, der Kommunikationsdienst und es gibt dann die Client Software mit der man sich dahin verbindet und ich denke, das ist schon sollte auch der Bundesnetzagentur,
einleuchten, dass ähm,
dass das zwei unterschiedliche Dinge sind, dass sie sich gerne nein, bitte nicht, aber sie könnten sich natürlich an die Betreiber von Jaba Servern wenden, aber mit Sicherheit nicht an die Hersteller und Vertreiber von der Software, die damit mit der man diese
in Anspruch nimmt.
Ja, so ein bisschen, als würde man jetzt irgendwie äh Mozilla anschreiben, weil in ihrem Webbrowser eine Webseite eines bestimmten, eine bestimmten Website, auf die sie aus sind, äh, angezeigt wurde.
Man kann ja mit man kann mit dem Browser auf so einen Webchat gehen.
Genau, also in ihrem Produkt wurde doch diese Webseite angezeigt, das müssen sie doch, äh, davon müssen Sie doch Kenntnis haben, also äh bitte, äh, wie, wovon reden wir jetzt.
Kommt, fragt man sich, wie kam die auf die Idee? Und ich hab ich habe mir gedacht, mit der gleichen Begründung könnten die sich ja dann irgendwie an Microsoft,
wenden, weil sie einen E-Mail klein namens Outlook haben, einen Apple wenden, weil sie einen E-Mail-Clintnams Mail, ein so, dann können sie ja jeden, jeden, der einen E-Mail-Klein vertreibt, anschreiben. Und dann habe ich mir gefragt, wie kommen die überhaupt auf die Idee, ne.
Jeden anschreiben, sozusagen, alle Programme können sie an.
Alle Programme könnten sie anschreiben. Und da gibt es dann ein Urteil des Verwaltungsgerichtes zu Köln zur Meldepflicht von E-Mail-Dienstanbietern,
Wie diese als Telekommunikationsdienste einstuft
dann sagt das Verwaltungsgericht Köln der Umstand, dass die Signalübertragung nicht durch den E-Mail-Diensteanbieter erfolgt, beziehungsweise über das offene Internet stattfindet.
Ist für die Einordnung des Dienstes nicht entscheidend, da der gesamte Kommunikationsvorgang
einheitlich betrachtet werden muss und die einzelnen Prozessschritte nicht getrennt beachtet werden können. Betrachtet werden können. Ich vermute damit bezogen die sich darauf, dass der,
E-Mail-Serveranbieter nicht sagen kann, meine E-Mails gehen aber durchs Internet.
Aber hier steht ja E-Mail-Dienstanbieter, das heißt Serverbetreiber und da kann man diese Argumentation natürlich aufrecht erhalten. Daraus macht die Bundesnetzagentur aber bei bei den Clients,
Ähm die Argumentation es handelt sich nicht lediglich um eine Software, sondern um einen Kommunikationsdienst, der auf der Grundliege des Grundlage des Client Serverprinzips erbracht wird,
Das findet nur im ganz besonderen Fällen Anwendung
Damit findet eine zumindest überwiegende Signalübertragung über Telekommunikationsnetze statt. Wie ist die legale Definition des Paragraph drei Nummer vierundzwanzig Telekommunikationsgesetz verlangt.
Hier meine Interpretation, was ich glaube, wovon die mittlerweile ausgehen. Jetzt jetzt schneide ich das erst.
Also ich meine, jetzt haben wir ja diesen letzten was,
acht Jahren sind's jetzt, sind wir in diese Mobile App World irgendwie rein, so und vor allem in diesem ganzen,
Online, Community, Chating, hast du ja einfach jetzt die Realität, dass jeder kleint im Prinzip auch immer für einen Dienst steht. WhatsApp, der Dienst hat WhatsApp, den kleint, ja?
Alle hängen irgendwie zusammen und glaube mittler.
SD nicht aufgef.
Die blicken sozusagen auf dieses Ding wie ah diese machen ja auch sowas,
Das heißt, wenn die einen klein sehen, der Xaba heißt, dann gehen sie sozusagen davon aus, dass es für den Xaba kleint, auch ein Xaver Server gibt und man sich zwar quasi,
ja oder dass man sich sozusagen mit Xaver natürlich nur, das ist sozusagen das Cover-Netzwerk ist, wo Xaver Clans mit dem Cuba Server äh Xaver User zusammenbringen, die sich da miteinander unterhalten,
WhatsApp halt nur WhatsApp User über den WhatsApp-Server zu WhatsApp Usern äh weiterbringt,
die haben überhaupt nicht die haben überhaupt nicht geschnallt, dass es sich hierbei um ein offenes Protokoll handelt und da jeder mit jedem reden kann.
Das heißt, wir haben uns jetzt so lange äh in diese scheiß Plattform treiben lassen, dass selbst die Bundesnetzagentur nicht mehr weiß, was ein Federadit-Service ist.
Ja oder was überhaupt ein Internetstarter ist. Also da da, also ich habe da keine andere Erklärung dafür. Oder? Also macht doch irgendwie Sinn, ne?
Ja, ja, ist irre, er ist irre, in welche verqueren Dinge du dich eindenken kannst. Nee, wirklich, muss ich sagen, da wäre ich nicht drauf gekommen, aber du hast recht. Wenn wir nächstes Mal bei der Bundesnetzagentur sind, nehme ich dich mit.
Danke.
Vielleicht kannst du den vielleicht.
Habe ich gewartet.
Ja, ist okay, ja okay.
Okay, liebe Bundesnetzagentur äh live. Hört mal Chaos Radio von vor zwanzig Jahren, dass das alles ausführlich erklärt worden. Oh war ja.
Dann, du hattest es gerade schon angesprochen, Laptopverbot in Flugzeugen.
Knallbomben.
Greift jetzt langsam um sich. Äh zunächst war das, glaube ich, die USA in Bezug auf irgendwie zehn Länder,
bei denen sie nicht wollen, dass wenn Flüge aus diesen Ländern kommen ähm irgendwas was größer ist als ein iPad oder so mit in den äh mit da reingenommen werden darf,
Ähm Frankreich wollte dann nachziehen und man fragte sich erstmal, was soll das denn, ne? Warum äh warum machen die das? Und ähm.
Natürlich konnte man sich dann denken, okay, die äh also bei den USA habe ich natürlich sofort die Vermutung, ja, die wollen, dass ich einfach für für zwölf bis vierzehn Stunden meinen Laptop aus den Augen lasse.
Gibt's in, in Influentertainment.
Oder nachher wie Julian Essange da sitzt und sagt, ah, weggenommen. Will ich aber wieder haben. Oder ähm eben ähm mit mit irgendeiner Wand oder mit irgendeiner Infektion herausgehe, also das geht natürlich steht natürlich nicht zur Debatte
Rechner,
aus der, also für längere Zeit vollständig äh aus der Hand gebe und in eine Tasche packen muss, äh die ein Schloss hat, äh was die TSA aufmachen kann, ne? Also das, das steht überhaupt nicht zur Debatte,
aber man muss sagen.
Nicht ohne meinen Laptop.
Es geht genau, ja. Aber ich fliege ja eh nicht mehr in die USA. Äh nächster Zeit, bis sie sich da, bis sie das da geklärt haben mit den Russen, ne? Ähm.
Es gibt aber eben Hinweise, dass äh die Energiedichte in Akkus eben tatsächlich reicht, um eine Explosion herbeizuführen, die dem Flugzeug selber nicht schadet,
Also wenn ihr es jetzt mitten im Frachtraum ist, ist die Gefahr nicht besonders groß.
Wenn man aber äh den Gerüchten glaubt, gab es im Februar zweitausendsechzehn in Somalia einen Anschlag, wo der Sprengstoff in einem Laptop versteckt wurde,
Und dann ähm
quasi in den in der Kabine am Fenster zu zur Explosion gebracht wurde und dadurch eben dem äh dem Flugzeug entsprechender Schaden zugeführt.
Ja, ich glaube, der wesentliche Schaden kam, in dem man meint, dem Attentäter äh nach, weil der wurde nämlich dann rausgesogen und äh rausgeflogen. Das Flugzeug selber könnte aber dann äh entspannt landen.
Äh so entspannt ist das glaube ich nicht, aber wir wollen jetzt hier kein.
Ne, aber es ist halt sonst keiner äh zu Schaden gekommen. Er hat sich sozusagen einfach selber aus dem Flugzeug rausgesprengt und mit dem Loch konnte der Flieger aber noch.
Das ist aber gefährlich und das ist ja ich sehe, ja, aus das Loch war schon ein bisschen größer.
War schon ein bisschen größer, aber ging halt noch. Okay. Halt eine ganze Menge aus diese Dinger, wenn sie wollen.
Ja
Ja, aber wir wollen jetzt nicht, weil wir wollen nicht über F.
Nein, das wollen wir nicht.
Wenn du so ein Loch in so einem Flugzeug hast, ne, dann ist dieser Fall eines eines nicht zu erwartenden Druckabfalls in der Kabine. Äh wenn dann nämlich die Sauerstoffmasken fallen und durch diesen Druckerfall haben die dann auch äh.
Tja, na ja, ich freue mich vorin, dass jetzt äh münden wird. Ich meine, wenn man jetzt irgendwie keine Sportgeräte mehr äh mit reinnehmen kann.
Ach so, Hacksportgerät. Ja. Nee, also du kannst, du kannst dann jetzt folgendes.
Trete auch kein Fünf-Stunden-Flug an. Ohne Device.
IPad kannst du haben.
Wozu lassen sie denn diesen ganzen Kack die ganze Zeit beschnüffeln.
Wird doch, ich hab doch hier gerade die Liste deiner Geräte gesehen, da wird doch eins dabei sein, was du mit an Bord nehmen kannst. Nimmst du dein Apple TV, kannst du aus der Steckdose.
Sehr schön. Muss ich auch noch meinen fünfzig Zoll Fernseher mit reinschleppen. Na ja.
Akku hat. Ähm nee, also das ist ein das ist natürlich äh total affig und ein äh und ein Problem.
Erkenne, wenn die das jetzt wirklich durchziehen,
Also als viel beruflich Reisender finde ich das vielleicht auch ganz gut, weil dann habe ich eine Ausrede, dass ich im Flugzeug nicht arbeiten konnte. Aber ähm.
Ähm also ich ich erkenne einen Markt für,
So Sicherheitspakete für Computer, Sicherheitsverschlussboxen für Computer? Wobei die würden sie natürlich dann auch wieder verbieten, weil könnte ja eine Bombe drin sein,
und äh ich sehe zunehmende Verkaufszahlen für so Wespery Preis und so. Weil dann musst du halt demnächst einfach ein Ort ein straffes Wesperypay haben ohne Akku
wo du eben sagen kannst, okay, ist groß genug, das ist Handgepäck, hier ist meine verschlüsselte SD-Karte
Oder eben du kommst eben du du wanderst dann eben mit deiner SD-Karte und hast vor Ort einen, ne? Sagst du also beim Kunden. Wisst ihr ja Bescheid, ich komme mit dem Flugzeug, ne? Stelle mir da schon mal eine Tastatur, einen Monitor und einen Respekt hin. Ich bringe meine SD-Karte mit. Solange sie mich die noch mitnehmen lassen.
Also am Ende stellt sich hier natürlich auch wieder die Frage, wollen wir uns irgendwie von diesem ganzen Terrorwahnsinn,
So dermaßen aus der Spur bringen lassen,
das sozusagen überhaupt gar kein normales Leben mehr möglich ist, weil.
Ich finde das aber auch geil,
Korrekt justiert Tim gefällt mir.
Wie sagt Loriot eins so schön? Der Mensch ist das einzige äh Tier auf der Welt, was während der während des Fluges noch eine warme Mahlzeit zu sich nehmen kann.
Wir wissen aber auch alle, wie das dann nachher aussah. Mit dem Rollbraten oder was.
Sie haben da eine Nudel. Ja.
Ähm so und dann noch, jetzt kommen wir wirklich Kurzmeldung. Stellt sich raus, Captain Obwirs hat eine Studie gemacht.
Der ist wieder unterwegs. Ist eine Studie gemacht.
Robbie ist halt eine Studie gemacht äh und es war halt die BNI Bundesnetzagentur.
Heute war echt im Fokus, ne?
Ist heute voll. Ich will gar nicht, ich bin jetzt, also ich kenne eigentlich gute Leute, bei der Benetzeige.
Naja, wir sind auf jeden Fall an der Front der Nachrichtenlage, so viel kann man schon mal festhalten.
Die haben gesagt, okay, wir machen hier mal äh eine Breitbandmessung äh und haben dann mit zweitausendfünfzehn angefangen und da haben irgendwie hundert noch was äh.
Leute dran teilgenommen, da konnte man irgendwie auf so ein, ja, auf so ein Ding klicken, da hat man quasi so einen Speed-Test gemacht, ne? Und dann ähm,
konnte man eben dann da sehen, wie schnell das ist und das Ergebnis der Breitbandmessung
wurde jetzt im Jahresbericht zweitausendfünfzehn, zweitausendsechzehn veröffentlichte eindeutig sowas von eindeutig mit Microsoft Word geschrieben wurde, das ist äh.
Auffällig ist. Ähm und stellt sich raus fünfzig Prozent der Nutzer,
erreichen im Festnetz mindestens sechzig Prozent der vertraglich vereinbarten maximalen Datenübertragungsrate.
Bei zwei Anbietern erreicht die Hälfte der Nutzer sogar mehr als neunzig Prozent der Vertraglich vereinbarten maximalen Datenübertragungsrate. Ähm es gibt also äh Unterschiede zwischen den Anbietern,
und in den einzelnen Breitband Bandbreite Klassen. Das kann aber das,
ist insofern gut zu erklären, weil die niedrigeren Bandbreiteklassen ja auch
oft da angeboten werden, wo das DSL unter widrigen Bedingungen operiert, also es entscheidend ist ja immer der Abstand zu
und weiter weiter wie es im im Chornetz dann aussieht weshalb in ländlichen Regionen dann eben irgendwelche mickrigen.
Zwei Megabit-Anschlüsse sind, weil einfach das Kupferkabel so lang.
Genau. Und da ist ein zwei Megabit-Anschluss, aber im Katalog wollte man zwei Megabit nicht stehen haben, deswegen zahlt's einen sechs Meter Megabit-Anschluss. Also ist dieser Effekt wahr zu erwarten.
Ja, wobei jetzt sagen wir mal langsames Internet, ja, nicht,
Zwingen nur auf diese Leitung zurückzuführen sein muss, sondern das eben auch sehr wohl sein kann, dass einfach die dahinter stehende Kapazität so nicht da ist und das sieht man ja ganz klar bei diesen
hohen Bandbreitenklassen, da ist von zweihundert bis fünfhundert Megabit die Sekunde die Rede und äh das betrifft halt im Wesentlichen eigentlich,
Fernsehkabel, basierte Internetanbieter
So hier Kabel Deutschland äh et cetera, die ja ohnehin prinzipbedingt schon ein Share-Medium sind, das heißt, wenn man da,
Anschluss hat und andere Leute im Haus oder im Block, je nachdem wie weit das trägt
auch dort bei demselben Provider Kunde sind, dann ist es eben nicht so wie bei DSL, dass jeder quasi so eine eigene garantierte Mindestgeschwindigkeit hat bis zum ersten Verteiler, sondern dass eben schon dieser erste Weg zum ersten Verteiler
Schon geteilt ist, sprich wenn alle Freitagabend dann äh ne noch vor der Tagesschau
nochmal ihre E-Bay-Verkäufer irgendwie äh absegnen wollen und vorbei nach Schweddorf machen, genau. Dann na ja, dann teilt man sich das Ganze, ne? Ist das wie ein gut ausgelastetes WLAN und äh so fühlt sich's dann natürlich auch an.
Unterschiede gibt's außerdem zwischen sicherlich auch zwischen den DSL-Anbietern selber, weil die natürlich und also die haben ja den,
da draußen steht ja nur ein Dieslem. Wenn du jetzt, ob du jetzt bei der Telekom bist oder bei eins und eins, da ändert sich ja erstmal nichts bis zum ersten
bis zum nächsten Hopp, aber dann entscheidet natürlich auch wie viel Infrastruktur, wie viel Kapazität hat derjenige Anbieter, bei dem du da bist, wie schnell kann der dich aus dem Internet rausscheuchen und wie gut ist der angebunden,
Ähm also das erklärt dann auch die Unterschiede zwischen den Anbietern. Im Mobilbereich erreicht lediglich dreißig Prozent der Nutzer mindestens die Hälfte der maximalen Übertragungsreihe gerade. Also,
Ein Drittel der Nutzer erreicht mindestens die Hälfte des Verheimbarten, das heißt zwei Drittel erreicht noch nicht mal die Hälfte.
Ich bin ja eh hier beim unter Unterschichtennetz. Ähm, bei stationären Anschlüssen, bei stationären Anschlüssen, also den die irgendwie,
Wo du LTE zu Hause hast, äh waren es mehr als siebzig Prozent. Vor allem hohe LTE-Geschwindigkeiten von dreihundert Mbit würden in der Praxis nur,
Ausnahmefällen erreicht. Also völlig wer hätte uns nur jemand gewarnt, ja? Das.
Das hätte ja auch mal einer ansprechen können.
Dann kannst du mal weiterscrollen im Bereich steht da vielleicht auch einfach mal wer der beste Anbieter ist ne.
Weiß nicht, du meinst die den Namen? Das kann ich mir gar nicht vorstellen. Hier wird noch viel über das Messkonzept.
Ja, zu dem Messkonzept hatte übrigens Alexander Lefmann vom CC auch äh vor einigen vor einigen Monaten äh,
Expertenauskunft an den Deutschen Bundestag abgegeben. Das haben wir hier aber auch erwähnt. Gruß an dieser Stelle, während du weiters Kreuz und nicht guckst, was als nächstes kommt, denn,
Es wird Zeit für.
Du meinst, es wird Zeit für.
Am dritten Mai findet im Landschaftspark Duisburg die zweite Eteration der Westwo Visions statt. Zu Gast sind Daniel Dummstadt Berg und den Had. Außerdem gibt es noch weitere Vorträge zum Thema IOT
und anderen Themen ähm der Eintritt sowie Speis und Trank sind vollkommen kostenlos. Man muss sich aber trotzdem vorher anmelden, weil es nur zweihundert Plätze gibt und wer den Landschaftspark Duisburg-Nord nicht kennt, der sollte da auf jeden Fall
allein deswegen schon hin.
Ja und am achten und neunten April zwanzig siebzehn gibt es einen Hackday bei Funk. Das ist ja dieses äh.
ARD für Junge, ne.
Ja so ähm da wird einiges ausprobiert.
ZDF für junge Leute.
Ja, ist glaube ich beim ZDF angesiedelt, aber ist halt sozusagen öffentlich-rechtlicher, macht jetzt äh auch mal äh andere Medien als bisher. Äh es gibt da einen Hackday vor Democracy, kostet keinen Eintritt, äh wohl irgendwie eine bescheidene Unterkunft gestellt.
Ja, eine Jugend Herr Berge.
Dich anmeldet, na ja, immerhin, ne? Ähm und ja, da ist dann auch Schluss, Reisekosten gibt's äh nicht, aber es wäre dann auch viel verlangt und das Ganze findet statt in der Zentrale von Funk,
in Mainz.
Mit Weitblick über Mainz.
Weitblick. Äh wollen wir hoffen, dass der Rest der Veranstaltung diesen Weitblick dann auch hat.
Dann findet im September das Hacken Open Air statt,
Dazu lädt der Stratum null ein äh nach Peine äh vom siebten bis zehnten September gibt es feinstes Hackercamping im UJZ Peine. Wir freuen uns, wenn ihr kommt,
unser Camp mit euren Villages, Workshops und Vorträgen bereichert. Tickets plus Tassen plus Shirts gibt es sofort im Presale,
und sie kosten fünfundsechzig Euro, das ist ein bisschen weniger als ein normales CC Camp. Äh klickt euch eure Tickets, wir haben limitierten Platz fürs Kampf für Surf, mehr Infos unter Hacken Open Air DE.
Ja, das äh waren sie dann auch schon unsere Termine. Ja. Oder?
Die Musik ist so schön.
Musik ist so schön, du meinst, da möchte man grad noch mehr Termine ankündigen? Ja, mehr gibt's nicht. Wenn ihr noch welche habt für uns, dann äh schickt sie doch mal rum. Wir nehmen das immer ganz dankbar auf. Wenn man dann mal äh das nicht vergessen, das anzukündigen. Das soll ja auch schon mal vorgekommen sein.
Vorstellen.
Ja, das bringt uns zu unserer beliebtesten äh Sektion.
Oh, welche ist das.
Das Ende der Sendung.
Freuen sich die Hörer, aber was.
Politisch ey.
Ja, also du hast ja war ja auch okay, was du ja gemacht hast, als ich weg war.
Die beiden Sendungen mit Thomas. Genau. Ja, ist immer äh,
Gut, wenn man mal hier wieder ähm externe Kompetenz auch nochmal mit äh reinbringt, werden wir demnächst ähm auch wieder machen.
Wenn wir sehr viel öfter machen.
Ja und wisst nicht, sonst noch irgendwas. Zugeernt werden, zu erzählen, erstmal nicht.
Nö. Wir haben heute schon so viel.
Erklärt und erzählt.
Erklärt und erzählt und.
Machen wir jetzt die Kiste zu.
Machen wir die Kiste zu und unterhalten uns noch so ein bisschen.
Genau und ihr hört dann nächste Woche wieder von uns. Bis bald.
Ciao ciao.